What do you mean an apex tournament with no shooting
involved?
No, okay, because I'm organizing it's mostly there's a lot
of melee involved.
There's a lot of beating people up with your fists, but
there's like not a lot of actual shooting involved.
And it's like each game is like its own.
I'm at prize pool.
And like, um, Doki's trying to get me to join an apex
tournament.
And live melee abilities only.
And there's, uh, I'm protected.
It'll be really fun.
line when you want to join it like so so the fact that the
fact that you're pushing how fun it is it is immediately
made me really wary right no it's because i'm trying to get
participants by this friday i was this i had like this
friday you find any participants already is there is there
something wrong with it no it's no it's because i've had to
or i've been I had a week to organize this.
Oh.
I had a week to organize this.
So I've been like, there's a chance that it's just me and
you and nobody else.
No, I have five other teams confirmed.
I have five other teams confirmed.
Oh, you didn't say that.
You didn't say that.
Well, I'm not like, no, you guys are not like the second
team.
You're not like, it's just me and you guys.
Like, I mean, that's what I thought.
just give you like yeah let's play apex and punch each other
yeah it's like it's like 10 teams and and you have five and
i have five confirmed and you guys could be right you guys
can be the six oh it'll be so fun i'll join if mint joins
that's what i said but i'll join if you join are you busy on
snuffy are you busy on friday well i gotta turn snuffy back
up all right all right snuffy are you busy on friday oh yeah
to snuffy at table no why oh do you want to join an oh my
god no no no no no it's it's like it's not there's no not a
lot of shooting involved it's like just hide and seek and
then like melee only wait that's kind of cute though do you
want to do you want to spend my friday doing it this I was
supposed to...
Yeah, you, man, and lab can be on a team together.
I'm cooking yakiniku that day.
I can't join.
And I'm so sorry.
No, no, no, it's before yak...
I saw your schedule.
It's before yakiniku.
Jake is like, you couldn't escape.
Before yakiniku, don't worry, man.
What time is it?
It's at 1 p.m.
PST.
1 p.m.
PST, so it's like 9.
In the middle of the day.
Oh, met Doki.
That's control resident day.
a lot of our friendship.
Oh, you are not going to get Lymo out of control, you're not
even playing it on that day.
You haven't finished control yet.
Not me, Lymo, Lymo.
It's me.
I've been waiting.
But you can do it after.
You can play it after.
So you think this 10-player Apex tournament isn't going to
take, like, six hours?
No, it could be, like, three hours.
Three hours?
Three hours to punch people.
There's several game modes.
It'll be three hours maximum.
Are you playing like crab game if it was Apex?
It's just a game.
That's essentially like if crab game was an Apex basically.
What?
And I'll join if Mint joins.
What do you win?
You can win potentially three grand per game.
You can win a sense of pride and accomplishment.
I haven't launched Apex in years.
Me neither.
It'll be so fun, guys.
So fun.
Are you playing, Doki, or are you just organizing?
No, I'm playing too, but don't worry.
Don't worry.
I won't kill you guys.
You have to be on our team.
Wait, wait, wait.
We are lifting the sloppies, but we won't be on the same
team.
Yeah, yeah.
What?
I'll team out, out, out, just gotta let me know what
characters you're playing, and I'll make sure we can, like,
link up, you know?
We can all be on the team.
What does that mean?
Anyone doesn't want to be in a call and they'll be like
where are you guys and I'll meet up with you guys at an area
Uh-huh.
Is this rigging the competition?
Yeah, I didn't seek is about hiding from each other.
How are you gonna?
Well, I'm the seeker.
So like Oh my god, wait, wait, wait.
I'll join if I can play mirage and nothing but mirage and
scan the fucking bamboozle button the whole time.
You can play Mirage.
You can play whatever the fuck you want, guys.
I don't even know the name of an Apex character.
It's high time.
It's so fun, guys.
You're going to have...
What's his name?
What do you mean?
That's from Overwatch.
Not even a strong-looking overwatchman.
What about this?
I can, I can, like, sub in and out, too.
Like, if you...
What do you mean you can sub in and out?
I would, like, you know, if one of you guys need to rest for
a game, I can cop in.
Wait, what?
Again, we're not going to be playing together?
I thought this was like, we're all going to be competing,
like, hunger games.
Each game is...
Each team is only three people.
So that's why I'm saying you, you, men, and I will all
together, like a family.
Where are you?
I'm on the other team, Bob.
What can I do about that?
I mean, what can I do about that?
What can I do?
You're moving in a bunch of people who don't play this.
Roping and lambs to the slaughter.
I haven't touched Apex in fucking years.
Some people here who has never ever touched Apex Uh-huh,
they're like they're like below they're like below the end
But then there's people like you here who have touched Apex
a lot and I will be restricted to melee only Like I can't do
anything either.
I can only punch you.
Are you all gonna like are you all gonna get punched by me?
There's no way I can I don't trust it We're good.
You're literally you're you're throwing us in there as like
sandbag yeah just so you win the prize no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no that's not no no no that's not how
it's gonna happen guys that's not how it's gonna happen if i
if i see in the kill feed if i see your name and it was me
that punched you guys out you could just stop you could just
say you could just not punch us right i was about to say if
i see in the kill feed that names oh yeah you can't be able
to see people's names like on the when they're engaging the
fight but you can knock each other down and i'll see your
name in the kill feed and then i'll and then i'll run i'll
leave you guys what if you don't look what if you don't look
look every guy i kill i'll look to make sure it's not you
guys i mean how bad could it be i have to deal with deadlock
be in comparison right it's not that bad it's not that bad i
love how agreeable you're being like reaching desperation
donkeys she's scared me she sounds like she's trying to be
like a demon she's making like a snake like a snake i don't
know about i got you guys like free breakfast at at this
meeting and i'm trying to sell you time shares right now
brought donuts
player is gonna feel about you Resikas.
Well, they won't.
I'm not Resing you guys.
I'm just leaving you guys.
I don't know.
You're gonna leave.
You're gonna you're gonna hire us onto this tournament.
We're not gonna make any money or win any games.
And you're gonna get out.
We're gonna have bond.
We're gonna have time.
You're not on our team.
There is no bond.
We're gonna spend time together as as a group of friends
have on different teams on different fucking teams and can
the other teams also kill us hey dokey hey dokey who's on
your who's on your who's on your team dokey who's on your
team stop i don't know yet i don't what do you mean you
don't it could be us it could be us pros and pros there
could only be three people on a team i gotta pick two of you
guys oh big drama i could only pick two of you yes you guys
understand now okay well since limo and mint have already
agreed to make time you know wait wait wait wait wait yeah
yeah yeah hold on hold on which two should i get ahead of
ourselves should we all and that is why we should all be in
this tournament together as a team but we're not you know
you know like when you get a facebook message from someone
and like hey hey guys how have you been it's so nice to talk
to you again and then they like come up with some utter it's
an mlm yeah like we're getting mlms by dokey yeah truly
you're about to ask me to test your minecraft game here's my
minecraft mod pack by the way can you click on the link and
download it for me real quick guys i swear to god it's so
fun stop saying that it's just scaring me
So guys, I'm going to mark you guys down as a yes.
Is that what we're as a strong maybe.
Strong maybe.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
A definite no.
Stop it.
I thought you said you were going to.
I thought you said you were down earlier and I would rather
stick my nose into the toilet than play this like scam that
you're selling me right now.
It's not a scam.
to god i swear to god it's not a scam and everybody's gonna
have a great time and i oh my god you need to work better on
your sales pitches yeah and i guys it's just i've been
trying i've had like it's four games three three days to
plan this guys wait i have a question i have a question
dokey yes if theoretically i joined your tournament and then
suffered a catastrophic inability to use my keyboard and
sandbagged out early would this be well you can't be you
can't sandbag early because each game is its own thing oh
and you would leave us you would leave us live no no no i'll
i would sabotage you that's different just like a family
we're so we're so lovely sloppy sisters okay yeah yeah okay
there's You got free skins.
For the game I don't play.
Yay!
But like, but, but, but it's free.
But it's free.
This is like that time, you know when we did the Marvel
Rivals tournament and won, and I got all that currency for
skins, and then dead stopped playing the game from that
moment onwards.
Yeah, but you still, you got it, though.
Yeah, no, I have all that current.
It's just sitting there.
Yeah, yeah, but you still, you still got it.
I still got it.
It's like the image of, you know, you've earned it, you
know.
The sense of pride and accomplishment.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like a pride of accomplishing.
You guys could, if you guys live to fourth place, you can
get money.
And out of 10 teams.
So you're saying trade our dignity for fourth place.
Out of 10 teams.
And it's like, how does it, you know.
I thought you said 10 players, 10 teams of three.
10 teams of three that's at least 30 people but but in a
regular apex match it would have been 20 teams so it's cut
in half so okay it's really very reasonable like you need a
great market rate there's only more people with more games
you have to play right you'll there's a 50% chance you can
you can place at least fourth place Like okay again as a
team or like as an individual As a team as a team It scored
his teams.
It scored his team Okay, okay.
I still think I would not want to do that I don't want to do
it I don't even know what the map looks like I don't even
know how to like play the game I'd be I know other people
would be hiding in the best places and we'd find literal
bushes And everyone would find that and everyone drops on
the apartments every fucking time and the lobby's dead in
like 10 seconds.
You already know 90% more than the other two as we share his
life.
The other two us?
Are you talking about us?
Yeah, it's like the other two.
I can name one apex map, so a huge advantage, huge
advantage.
You can name a map and a game?
Yeah, a map in the world, I don't know.
I know an apex character.
It's high time.
It's time with the right fucking clothes, man.
You know,
it sounds like you kind of like merged, merged Cassidy and
Namur or something.
And Namur's the whole list.
No, it's high tide.
And he just like floods the arena or something in Marvel
Rivals.
That'd be great.
Well, he does say it's high tide when Cassidy has his beach
skin on.
Who are these beaches?
oh i i i only played overwatch one and a very small amount
of two that's the truth so so guys you guys want me to mark
you guys down as a as a wow you were so convincing i
honestly i honestly think it depends on whether or not i
feel better because i i am brainwashed right now yeah no i
am i am so bad like you're bullying a sick I wasn't patient
zero someone decided to super spread gaslight oh one person
I don't know I don't know but like I swear half of expo is
sick maybe a lot because there's there's some people who are
like yo my nose is bleeding is this normal and it's like no
that's just your brain hemorrhaging don't worry about it my
nose is fine I think my brain matters safe but oh my god I
just That's crazy.
I just keep coughing and sneezing and sniffling and it's the
worst.
Oh my god.
That's pretty bad.
You're gonna turn into like a fungus.
It's bad enough, Doki.
I was playing Deadlock Doki and I was taking the double
sinners and I failed basic math and was like, yeah, I can do
one last hit to finish this sinner off.
Did one last hit fucking die, dropped a 1k bag?
My team ran into the fucking sinners because they thought
I'd gotten jumped by the enemy team.
And they were like, did you die to the fucking sinner?
and I was like, no, yes.
They were just like standing in the entranceway staring at
me as I did my walk of shame to get my bag.
Oh, that's our rem.
I wasn't even rem, I was fucking Mina.
I was Mina.
That's our Mina.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I got my hat.
I got my suit on.
Yeah, sorry.
I was in the back.
Yeah, we're in the back rooms, guys.
Oh shit, sorry.
realize so guys uh don't say this is about apex don't say
don't oh yeah for those you don't know on friday on friday
i'll be hosting an apex tournament for apex legends my no
idea and you're gonna see me and the sloppy sisters there on
friday yeah you know friday is also uh by the sloppy sisters
you need to draw this collab isn't it i would send a video
message saying good luck All right, okay, I'll take that.
I'll take a video.
Wait, yeah, yeah, can we just, can we just like be mascots
and send moral support?
Oh my God, wait, do we like that one like cowboy video where
you're like in the sky just being like, good luck, dokey.
Like like green screened in the sky?
Yeah, yeah, put us in, put us in.
You should change it so it's like the Hunger Games where
they do the canon.
Honestly.
You would, that would work better for me.
be on my team you know i have unless yay unless anyone wants
to volunteer themselves to be part of my as trivia and and
you know you know i have fun i i do enjoy i do enjoy fun
yeah it's gonna it's gonna be really fun that's how mint is
so quiet right now it's like like don't pick me teacher
don't feed me oh i'm doing the tutorial oh you know what
it's a tutorial miss miss like her sights based on movement
and she's just not oh my gosh i didn't know there were
bananas in this game desperately trying to stay and change
the subject we're playing back rooms today yippee yippee oh
yeah also by the way guys wait did i not have the right game
wait what is this one but uh pre-orders for the sloppy
sisters gina oh yeah that's why we're here guys this week
this week this week it's like this week was it 25th or 27th
25th 25th 25th on the day of my apex legends street fighter
unrelated unrelated it's unrelated unrelated but don't
you're killing me in real time it's on the same day guys
unrelated let me put the image up but i have a pen in my
chat for those who want to check it out guys you pre-order
join our i realized like after the stream was over when we
announced it it was seemed like we were recruiting people to
our fraternities or sororities yeah yeah i thought that was
the point no i thought i was like originally i was just like
oh yeah it's not b university but i was like wait it's like
joining a fraternity yeah i thought it was true i thought
everyone kind of has like their own little like aesthetic to
yeah i hate people definitely be like do people do people in
like real real real life in american like colleges actually
do those like crazy yes basically like torture entry exams
some of them yeah that's that's crazy that's crazy i went to
university of course it was like an art university but
nothing like that happened to me sometimes they do chance in
the sewers i the sewers where the fuck is your university
I'm not gonna talk to myself, don't you?
Give me a name, address.
The year I graduated.
Yeah, what class were you again?
I know like for my university, they did hazing where it was,
it was like, you know, it's from Canada and it's snowing.
And then apparently the guys, the guys were doing hazing for
their fraternity and they were all running like streaking
naked in the snow.
Oh.
Yeah.
That sounds more like a good time than torture.
It was...
Snuffy, it was...
Okay, wait, you're American, so I don't know how to convert
it to...
Oh, wait.
To, like, Freedom Units.
Oh, I know Celsius.
Oh, Celsius.
Mint, do you know Celsius?
I know Celsius.
Oh.
I don't... I don't sound...
That does not sound very good.
What do you mean?
It's true!
What's room temperature in Celsius, Mint?
Yeah.
What's room temperature in Fahrenheit?
Yes, but that doesn't matter because only Americans use
freedom units.
What do you mean it doesn't matter?
I don't know.
Actually, I don't know what room temperature is normally.
Normally, Celsius is abnormal, huh?
No, in general.
What's 10, 20 degrees Celsius to Fahrenheit?
That's like...
Like...
I'm pretty sure it's over...
That's not bad.
Wait, you know the conversion?
It's... You don't even know?
Why would I know?
I hear you...
I hear your keyboard.
I hear it...
Yeah, because I'm fact checking her.
I'm gonna fact check her.
It's actually 68.
It's 68 apparently.
degrees i was so close yeah but fahrenheit 10 degrees is a
lot so fahrenheit 10 degrees that's really cold i know what
that one is
i'm trying to find the picture of the genicle at the show
actually right now give me a sec guys you should get you
should get the one where it was like the video playing but
it was actually the fucking spider-man comic panel instead i
mean that one was good so i'm sorry they're like tear
tactile not included spider-man not included i've been like
showing off the the the detail shots i'm trying to download
oh i should download there we go yeah where are they send
them in the discord please what do you mean where are i only
have mine i only have mine diner for yours that's i that guy
doesn't do anything whoa uh leaks leaks
here guys here's the details of the oh i already had it
saved here's the details i i'm i'm going to go use the
bathroom i need to i need to also get more like i need to
pull my nose beer bake okay okay i saved my picture all
right guys here's what they look like for my collection
here's what they look like for my collection here's what
they look like for my collection at gina draws.com
collection wait slash collection slash sloppy my collection
here's my collection now here's my collection mine look at
that beautiful beautiful look at these colors beautiful yeah
i've heard many people say that i have the most swag so i'm
just you know i'm not i'm just fact stating what was our
stated not my own opinion but i have heard rumors about your
swag from you know the swag produced on if you were to join
my fraternity you know i don't know much about hazing but i
have heard stories i think we would probably tie you to a
tree we go into sewers and we chant it's specifically in the
sewers no i remember there were stories at my at my campus
that people would walk by the sewers and hear chanting well
are you sure it's fraternity and not a fucking cult oh i
don't know i mean why would they do it at school then that's
weird i don't know it could be the ninja turtles the ninja
turtles yeah they're going to school too man yeah they have
to go they have to get higher education too you think
they're just gonna uh lay around and not look out for their
careers after ninge being ninjjas Cowabunga.
You gotta be ninjas forever, guys.
You gotta look into their futures.
Why can't they be ninjas forever?
Because there's no 401k being a ninja.
What?
That's never guaranteed.
Yeah, yeah.
What is their retirement fund gonna look like?
Are they investing in anything for their future?
Are they...
Wow!
I think...
They're turtles.
How long do they realistically...
Actually, they live a long time.
They live a long time.
Yeah.
They just have a long time.
their time to be ninjas.
Yeah, exactly.
Let them be ninjas for longer.
It's like having a career injury.
They can't, it's like if someone does basketball and they
fucked up their knee or some shit, they can't go back to
basketball and then they're fucked.
Well, maybe they make money.
They live in New York.
They're probably really well off.
They live in the sewer, stuffy.
That means they have no rent.
They have to, they get to save everything.
Yeah, maybe they have, this is why they're going to college
now.
What's their income from being a ninja?
Huh?
Where do they get free food?
Pizza.
That's all they need.
Pizza and the sewers.
I mean, free house, free food.
What if they want to settle down, look for a family, look
for a wife.
They're looking for a family.
Look for a family?
I don't think turtles even have wives.
I don't think they need them.
I don't know.
I think they were...
produced like asexually or something wait okay wait that's
never mind hi did i miss anything i just seen a video about
the turtle was about to show us how turtles have sex i think
so i think actually that's what she was about to show us it
was a famous turtle video okay not famous but it's a funny
tiktok meme of a turtle just meme of a turtle about to what
about to what just having a good time having a good time so
if it's not famous how did you find this because it showed
up on my twitter feed that's how i get most of my new
services and you're saying because he's having a good time
he doesn't reproduce asexually yes why what yes that's what
it means
what welcome back funny turtle vine i literally am i gonna
watch this did you wait did you link it i'll man did you see
this tutorial for the game i'm gonna link it in the collab
it's not really a tutorial it's just a little area i'm going
through so like neemie and uh matara would see the video if
they ever look up the server for for educational i'm glad
you made this obtainable for access for all anybody to miss
out on this free and for me funny turtle vine panting
3.6 million views 3.6 million views i'm scared i don't
understand what's happening in this video there's nothing
happening you're clearly not don't have volume on i mean
he's panting but there's not even like you know there's
nothing else you can't even see if there's other turtles.
This is not proof.
There's a turtle right below him!
You see the shell!
It's gonna easily be a rock.
Oh man.
I'm not watching, I'm not watching the video.
It's not, it's safe for work.
It's safe for work.
It's not!
How is this not safe for work?
I've linked it in my chat!
Yes!
You linked it in the chat!
How many of these views are yours, Doki?
Why would it be me?
It's like, it's like four views.
That's a lot.
Was it the last hour or what?
Plus one was with you guys.
I didn't watch it.
I didn't click it.
No, but I clicked it just because I was trying to find the
video for you.
And then he watched it again.
Yeah, because I wanted to make sure it was the right video.
And you remember every aspect of it.
Well, it's a funny video.
Yes.
was funny i would god do you have any idea how hard it is to
find a video or sorry find a game on the twitch directory
just by typing back rooms there's like 60 billion yeah
there's a lot of clean up yeah it's clean up crew i found
yeah we're the clean up crew yeah we're here at post back
rooms wait should we make a lobby we should how do we how do
we i just realized it's been 30 minutes and we're still not
in the back room no no all right Alright, I haven't seen the
movie, so I'm not gonna get any awesome references.
Me neither, I don't think it's movie related as much.
I've seen the movie.
I haven't seen the movie.
I saw the movie after all the memes, so it ruined it for me
because every conversation was just like, haha, just like in
the Roblox game.
What?
What is happening with the spoiler?
Someone made a fucking Roblox backrooms game where you play
like a, like you play Clark's, everyone's a Clark.
and you and that's a Clark.
That's amazing.
Clark is the main character from Backrooms.
And he's like, he is very quotable because he says things
like I'm a fucking architect.
And like, it's just the way you're marked over and over
again.
And he like, he does that.
And then there's like Captain Clark, which is like the
tires.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes, the pirate version.
Yeah, it's the pirate.
And so other, like there's other players who are Captain
Clarks and they have to chase the Clarks.
And then it's just like millions of them running around
going like, I'm an architect, and it's just a way of a wired
over and over again.
So it just ruined the movie for me.
It's like a serious scene about him.
Is that what happens in the movie?
Not that specific scenario.
I mean, he says the lines in the movie.
I don't think he gets chased around by Roblox players.
Why not?
He gets chased by thousands of pirates or something.
I mean, he gets chased by, well, actually, he doesn't really
get chased by the pirate, but there's a pirate in it.
There's a pirate in the movie.
Oh.
You should watch the movie.
I'm gonna stay in character.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, stay in character.
Stay in character.
I'm doing the tutorial now too.
I don't think you have to do it.
Yeah, I think you could just make the lobby.
Yeah, just make the lobby.
Make the lobby.
Okay, who's- Come on, bird.
Bird.
You're clearly making the lobby.
We talked about this.
All right, give me a sec.
I'm gonna do the tutorial real quick.
It's done.
I've been like- I've been cleaning off the arrows on the
walls.
I'm like, I'm so done with talking about turtle sex.
I just don't want to do anything.
That was just like five minutes.
Five minutes of turtle sex is a long conversation.
It's too long.
What do you mean?
Wait, there are bananas.
Yeah.
How do you make the nozzles bigger?
I feel like I don't think you can.
Oh, there's like, if you scroll wheel, you can change the
type of not.
Oh, there's like a huge one.
All right.
Let's see.
How do I make multiplayer?
Uh, wait, how do I invite you guys?
I'm trying to figure this out.
I'm getting rid of the tutorial.
I'm pressure washing it off.
I'm done with this.
Uh, have you been enjoying crime scene cleaner a minute?
have you played it it's one of my favorite games ever
kowalski's so funny so good it's so good it's it's beautiful
i love it so much i was so glad when they came out with like
the second part and everything i just like how he wanders
into a room and someone's been like deep fried by like a
he's basically like you know the see the csi memes where
it's like looks like she i don't know like and they used to
make some horrible looking like she looks like she a pun but
my brain is mush yeah i don't know looks no he's got great
wasn't the only thing for dinner i got the i got the god
code guys oh there's a code yeah yeah you gotta do the uh
you gotta join from back in the lobby area yeah that's where
press escape and then do most press multiplayer or do we
hide it just in case it like shows the thing does it show
the code oh it does i don't know okay it does show the code
everybody join lobby by code okay But yeah, it's basically,
I just think Kowalski is really funny because of like the
really weird deadpan, like, like, line delivery and stuff.
Yeah.
He's, it's, it's so good.
I had a good time with it.
Yeah, because it's a story game, too, right?
You live.
Yeah.
It was Gabriel.
Wait, your name is Lawson.
Your name is Gabriel.
Oh, oh, cool.
I can, angel.
Wait, what?
Are you guys in?
Yeah.
Nikita.
I'm Nikita.
Wait, how do you guys see them?
Oh, you have name tags.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, is there no invoice game?
Like, no.
Sure, man.
I don't think we're in there.
We need him is Shiree.
Shiree.
What's my employee benefit?
Let's go start the mission.
I'm going to go all the way to the other side.
Oh, my hard work.
I noticed we couldn't like change our name or our suit
color.
It was like, no, you must unlock green.
I know.
I couldn't get green.
Oh.
All right.
Oh, okay.
Go in.
All right, guys.
Stop.
What the heck is all of this?
Hello, cleaner.
Hey.
This is Hawkins.
M Corp.
Senior co-assistant.
I can go in here.
Thank you.
You're too short.
I just jumped.
I just didn't.
You're too short.
No, no, you're too short.
I literally see you.
I'm missing you.
I'm not listening to this man at all.
It is our steadfast company policy.
Where's the garbage at?
I'm pretty sure everything is.
Useless shit pile.
Oh, there's garbage here.
Garbage?
Where's the garbage can that we throw things in and they
explode?
Useless shit pile.
I like the body physics and crime scene cleaner.
I like trying to toss things into the car.
Who's redacted?
Who are you?
Me.
What?
Hey.
Oh, we're redacted now.
I guess because we're in the back rooms.
Is that a thing?
Oh, that's true because we can't like let people know who we
are.
Is that a rule in the back?
No, because we're like secret undercover.
Like we're, it's like NDA.
We all signed an NDA to clean the back rooms.
I didn't sign nothing.
But we ran into the back rooms together.
So we totally already saw her.
are like name tags yeah oh there it is but we don't want we
don't want people other people in the back oh yeah why is
there so much litter in here you don't want the bad guys to
know what your name is though yeah yeah the rat like you
guys know the back rooms lord right like use honestly i
never did much with back rooms i like scp better it's just
basically like uh are we gonna actually get a touch in the
back rooms anybody can get into the back rooms because it's
like a basically so you can call in through the back rooms
yeah you enter it through the clark's furniture store yeah
yeah yeah so there's different entrances to the back rooms
um so like we could bump into some random dude from like i
don't know from from the uk that hopped in from the back
rooms that sounds awesome nobody lives in the uk it'll be
stupid oh sweet the best way to travel i just found out bob
the builder's british guys bob the builder is british That's
what I was saying!
It's because America re-dubbed the show to make him sound-
Wait, were you?
You fucking re-dubbed Bob the Builder?
What the hell?
Bob the Builder was different the whole time?
That was like my favorite show ever!
I was a long-running community joke!
My first ever crush was...
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Who is it?
Oh!
Clean it!
Clean it free!
Clean the sandals!
Ah!
Oh my god, there's like great mechanics!
No!
Ah!
What is this?
Okay, we got it?
That's, that's, I don't know What is that?
Who died?
Wait, clean it, clean it!
Okay, we cleaned you.
You know we cleaned you.
You cleaned my soul.
I cleaned your soul.
We got this.
All right, we got it.
Very good.
I think that was it.
I think.
Oh my god.
Anyway, we have sigil power, whatever that means.
Actually originally a British TV show.
And then in America, we re-dubbed it for some reason.
What?
They learned so much though.
They were like you couldn't expose them to British accents.
They'll be terrified.
all the children that's they knew that the pepah pig would
happen you know because now the children speak with British
accents because of that true they knew back then they didn't
want the kids to grow up to be is that like a confirmed
phenomenon is like a pepah pig like accent development and
babies it's like bluey's blood all over this floor yeah
bluey makes people Australian.
Wait, does it really?
Yeah.
It takes you Australian to watch it.
Louis makes evil Australian.
What the heck?
Man.
Mom has too many, like, cozy roads.
You know, that's how you know it should have never been
American is there's too many, like, one-lane little, like,
farm roads.
Wait.
I can't believe it.
Why won't they?
How do I, how do I, like, bin items?
I picked a bunch of them.
Oh, you just throw them.
Oh, my God.
You threw the trash yeah i was trying to i was trying to do
really good i was trying to make it is this weird oh it's
supposed to go in here yeah i was trying to make it all
explode when you just take it you know you just kind of
throw it away i wonder what other shows they re-dubbed in
american just because they just didn't like american i feel
like there was a lot more french canadian stuff than I ever
knew possible.
H2O wasn't good.
No, please.
You changed the name of a book series I read as a child
because they thought, I guess they thought that Americans
would struggle with like the concept.
Well, there's two.
There's one where it was like the philosopher stone became
sorcerer stone.
And then the other one was like, they changed it to compass
instead of.
Ah, there's a place.
Okay, see, I'm cleaning.
I'm cleaning.
Cleaning, cleaning, clean.
Cleaning.
Oh, Jesus!
Oh, is everybody okay?
Help!
Spray our souls.
Ah, I want to get the soul.
Wait, wait, wait.
Polish my balls.
Please, please clean our souls.
I'm cleaning.
I'm cleaning your souls.
Watch out.
Oh!
Okay, we got it.
Go.
You gotta clean your soul.
Okay, cleaning your soul.
All right, all right, let's get This one.
Oh, oh.
Watch out.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, it's up here.
I really don't want to get cleaned.
Throw it.
Oh, my God!
Cleaning.
Cleaning, clean, clean.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
You guys got blood everywhere.
Come on.
You didn't, you didn't revive and like your hips are, your
hips are thrusting.
Why are your hips thrusting at death?
Oh my God.
Oh my, what are they doing?
My hips don't lie.
I didn't get my balls washed enough.
Wait, everybody got revived, though.
I washed your balls.
Oh.
I said the word ball and now Dookie Dog got excited.
Ball?
Where's Ball?
What's up there?
My name changed.
It says my new name is Lila.
I'm no longer Gabriel.
Wait, how do you know your name?
I guess...
Because when you die...
a new new guy takes over uh and it says your name is now
yeah your name is like flashed in the corner for a second uh
i have been reborn welcome to feed my dog give me a sec guys
i'm gonna take my five minute break uh smoke break i have a
great deal died oh oh yay why did we only get a silver We
were slow because people died.
Oh, I think we're slow.
Unlocked blue.
I'm a blue.
Wee-face.
I got a net.
I'm a purist.
I want to be yellow.
Yellow?
Yeah, because it's like canonical.
That's like the back room's color.
Okay.
True.
Zero deaths, baby.
Zero deaths.
Let's go.
Doki.
Doki went for her smoke break and she left me with her dog.
or lima was that your dog my dog no my dog's quiet he's a
good boy your dog is this am i crazy do you it's mine it's
mine it's actually just me in the corner yeah sorry oh she's
the host oh my gosh okay well why don't she why don't she be
your backs i'm gonna take this opportunity to like tinkle
really quick i'll be okay looky-dark how are you feeling
lima I'm so sniffly.
Oh no!
Oh, Snuffy went to go tangle.
Yeah, Snuffy went to his bathroom.
I guess we just...
Oh, you guys can choose two colors if you want.
You did well embracing our Leave No Trades motto.
Praise my game volume a little.
He was really quiet in the actual back rooms, but in here
he's quite loud.
Yeah, I know, right?
I can't ignore him.
I love the employee benefits terminal.
I mean, he's our boss though.
He wants to be blue.
and acquire new looks.
I think I'm waiting for you.
Snuffy, I think, probably.
Informs me that usage of the terminal increases a cleaner's
field efficiency and limb retention metrics by statistically
significant margins.
Yeah.
Wait, your name is vagrant.
Hashing your F-corp credits today.
Your Freya now.
Freya.
Oh my God.
What happened to our old selves?
They got fired.
They died.
I didn't die.
You're Olgan.
What are these names?
Oh, look at it.
Kate.
The International Facility.
Olden.
What's my new name?
You're Old Gov. Old Gov. Oh, wait.
It is Old Gov. Oh, you're right.
I thought it was Old Gov. What's my name?
Kate.
You're just Kate.
I like how your name's in a heart.
I know, right?
Vagrant.
Vagrant in a heart.
And then we got Kate here.
Kate.
yeah kate from hr try and why are you why are you moving
dick first i mean like the way that you oh ew don't don't do
it slowly ew you're just calm down calm down first man what
do you what does this look like here watch watch watch this
is you
he's my way downtown I hear snuffy, can you guys?
She's not back yet.
She went to pee.
Yeah, she's still peeing.
Oh, you're right.
It's a very long pee.
She's doing this right now.
Incursion Research Terminal.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
Old Gov. Old Gov. Yeah, that's not right.
You're old Gov now.
What happened to Lila?
Dead.
Lila's dead forever.
Oh my god.
Change your color.
Go become blue, Snoopy Snoopy.
Blue, blue, blue.
Did you guys listen to him talking about how to upgrade your
nozzles and stuff?
Okay, it's that terminal.
Here, over here.
Am I blue?
Yes.
Oh, I spent it all on nozzle.
Wait, where do you, oh, we're here?
Nozzles, guys.
I should not have spent it.
Nozzles good.
Clean foster.
I don't think it's shared money, is it?
It doesn't look like it.
No, it's not shared.
you can spend your own yeah this is the first time in any
game that i feel like we've actually gotten points to do i
know this game is weirdly functional i did like that when i
launched it it was like would you like lumen ray tracing i
was like jesus christ i know right yeah that was crazy you
understand what that meant man don't yeah what i know you
didn't understand what that meant no No.
All right, what's lumen ray tracing, man?
Oh, no, I didn't understand.
This game runs really bad.
It's breaking for me all the time.
If you, I mean, if you go to settings and then go to
graphics, turn the global illumination quality, reflections
quality, and shadow quality down.
Oh, I did already.
But, like, yeah, I did.
It's not on lumen high?
Oh, okay, it just runs like shit.
Yeah, it just runs bad.
What's your specs, man?
What's your spec?
My spec?
oh well it keeps it keeps screen tearing for me really bad
oh turn v-sync on is i don't think there was one was there
that did i don't know i might it's in it's in video it's in
video oh and video yeah you turn v-sync oh that i didn't
check there yeah really that would be the first thing oh yay
no i went under graphics that's why oh yeah it's true yeah
sometimes it's graphics it was on ultra i forgot i had it on
high though whatever it's fine it worked everything down and
it worked anyway though oops yeah yeah all right let's go to
i'm going to the second area i wonder if there's a faster
way to do this oh it worked all right analysis rest assured
that attacks suffered by f corp workers during the last
mission are being taken seriously as your safety is our
utmost concern we have dispatch C-group scientists to
investigate.
While we're still awaiting our initial findings, Redactus
issued a new cleanup request to attach coordinates.
Alright.
It's true.
Since crime's being cleaner, I can't actually clean without
knowing the backstory first, so this is important to me.
Yeah.
Okay.
I feel like the eyes might sense.
I think things just spawn in.
It doesn't really matter if they...
Cleaning, cleaning, cleaning.
Is this like by the same people as the other cleaning?
I don't think so.
I mean to put the idea and then be like, what if it's in the
back rooms?
Yeah.
Because like the back rooms is like, uh, nobody can
copyright the back.
But it's also like open source.
Oh, we're the trash cangle.
We're the trash cangle.
Hey!
I know!
No, no, no, no, no.
I feel like there's going to be something to do with the
eyes.
What do we know is considered junk, though?
What if someone just wants to...
I just started taking everything.
Yeah, everything is junk.
Everything is junk.
A public domain.
That's what I'm...
Yeah, it's a public domain.
There you go.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's public domain?
The backrooms.
Yeah, because it's what's made on the internet.
Internet lore.
Yeah, it was from a public domain.
public forum so technically it's like by anonymous person.
Am I a public entity?
Are you a public domain?
Are you on the internet?
I know.
But I was born on the internet?
I'm like a public domain.
Oh, lights are gonna go.
Yeah, we're about to lose.
But you own the copyright of yourself.
Because these circles are like some Jungi Ito shit.
It is.
Oh, that's true.
Because the back rooms nobody owns the back rooms.
I would have taken credit for that.
I don't know who, like, missed out.
I would have said, yeah, some way.
That's my invention.
I did that.
I know, like, what's the movie company behind the back
rooms?
Uh, Hollywood.
John movie company.
Yeah.
Because I know they tried to trademark the back rooms in
some way.
Oh.
Oh, they tried to trademark.
the wallpaper of the back rooms the wallpaper yeah yeah
that's kind of the key i mean i guess if you think about it
it's a that happens for the visual style of it so i get it
no there's a thing to do those okay oh it's the same things
it's the same things clean the sigil oh here i'll keep i'll
keep going up here i'll keep getting this guy
I'm washing you.
You're so dirty.
I got it It's really hard to see where the explosion is.
Where's this?
Oh, there's the last sigil.
Oh, I didn't even see that.
You mean that the one right in front of us?
I didn't see the one on the floor.
I wish I had like soap.
Yeah.
I don't know about the wallpaper thing because like
apparently some guy actually owned the actual wallpaper from
the back rooms.
Like not because they went to the back rooms, but it was
like just some old wallpaper.
by the back rooms aren't real somebody said that the back
room no somebody in my chat said they were in wisconsin is
that what is there no like real back rooms i fully believe
that oh yeah it's apparently a wall it was like or an office
building oh you mean the place that they actually took the
original picture i was like i thought you're really
clarifying that the back rooms is not actual back in
wisconsin i thought maybe it was real like it just was like
not the lore but it was like you know because the liminal
photo of the back rooms had have been taken somewhere yeah
yeah it was it was pre-ai yeah which is very scary now it's
like how everyone knows where the amazing amazing digital
circus was yes i've been yes oh you wanted to
don't forget the guns those also count when you die you have
to clean them up oh you guys yeah you a mess you squirt your
blood everywhere yeah you really do make a big old oh i'm
sorry i'm sorry for me i'm sorry for my body is having you
should be sorry for not cleaning up after your nasty bodily
flu is on the floor okay i love that i can like throw these
from all the way up here my body mint do you ever try
trick-shotting bodies into the into the car yes and i do i
do it i do it it's yeah it's so funny you guys be like uh
over the over the corner off the rim and into the basket.
Yeah, I did a sick shot literally yesterday.
Wait, yeah, now you can lift it up and...
Oh.
Where is it?
Oh, my God.
One's in front of me.
I got the one in front.
That's a lot of explosions.
We should be five.
Oh, bump, bump, bump.
I should be five.
There's the giant pillar, spiky pillar here.
Got one.
Got one, too.
Oh, on me, on me.
He's one, he's one.
He's one, one shot, one shot.
Don't die, you guys.
Shields cracked, shield cracked.
Practicing for Friday.
Yeah, well, shield cracked.
Shields cracked.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
I'm reloading, I'm reloading.
Cover me, cover me, cover me.
I think that's the last thing.
Oh, I got knocked, I got knocked.
Yay.
Oh, yeah, good.
We're so good at this game.
Oh my gosh, I can't worry about that.
Oh, but we started calming.
Dark green!
Lival!
Yay!
Guys, when we started calming, guys, I think we got Friday.
I think Friday was going to go so well.
For all of us.
Yeah, you guys sound excited.
Good luck.
Yeah, including you, Stuffy.
No, I don't even know anything.
You guys are all making references.
I don't even understand.
I don't...
Yeah, nice gun.
I'm shooting.
shooting like that's all I can say I don't know I don't know
I'm running I'm crying I'm shooting I'm in the corner right
now I hear a lot of gunshots I don't know I won't even know
which one my own teammates are like it'll be so bad I don't
know your own teammate not intentionally luckily there's no
I might all right are you guys ready for oh the next Ward is
a red suit color, guys.
Oh, we're going to get promoted.
Wow.
Are you guys ready for the next mission?
Yeah.
Oh, I forgot to read the lore.
I guess we'll never know what happened.
I don't know how to actually haven't been listening to you.
To be fair, I'm used to it.
Just in case people didn't notice in the tutorial, you can
press right click so you don't have to hold the spray button
down.
Oh, I forgot to upgrade.
My god.
Oh, you can hold it?
Yeah, you can you can just press right click instead of left
click and it will like spray it hasn't been an incident here
can i ask you guys a personal question jay uh-huh how do you
wash your feet in the shower like do you guys have like one
of those little brushes well they're like do you do you just
scrub it like normally like any body part do you have like
brushes like what what brush are you talking about you you
can get a brush for like abrasions so because like some
people get like hard skin on the bottom of their feet selfie
what the fuck is wrong with your toes no no no it's not like
a no no those are like pumice stones for like you know I
just used the luffa thing that like the shower poof thing
which uses that same as every hand I hear like those those
aren't actually good for your body in general I haven't like
died yet so like it's like I'm not healthy for your yet I
mean it's just not healthy for your skin type deal to have a
I mean, if you're going crazy with it, probably not.
But, you know, I'm just, I'm not, like, raking it across my
skin till I bleed.
I found a body.
I'm going to toss it in the trash.
Whoa!
There it is.
He's like, he's like wiggling like he's in low gravity or
something.
It's the back room.
What's his name?
What's his name, Zara?
Let's look at his name.
What's his name?
Remember him.
Sean?
We'll remember you, Sean.
I'm going to put you in the trash now by Sean.
Oh my god.
It's like Sean never existed.
He didn't.
Leave no trace.
I have a feeling he's gonna come back.
What was that?
What's that?
It's Sean.
I told you.
It's the spirit of Sean.
I'm so scared.
He's gonna escape.
Kill it.
Oh my god.
It sounds like counter strike.
We're playing counter strike.
It sounds like the- We're in training.
What is he doing?
Is he like pooping out something?
What's going on with him?
He's throwing bananas at us.
don't go close to him oh oh we throw bananas little snacks
at us yeah sean's such a prankster i know i'm glad he's dead
explode yeah he was pretty annoying yeah you know how i i
swear he was eating like from our from the fridge from the
community fridge those were my bananas i think it was You
know, I thought it was a community fridge if it's not for
the community.
Yeah, but then my...
I wrote my name on it.
Yeah, I wrote my name on a sticky note.
I thought that just meant that you left it for me because
you're so nice.
Am I supposed to throw these away?
No, I...
Throw everything away.
Damn it.
I was in the middle of that.
Oh, more, more?
Stop trying to commute with Sean.
Where are the evil sigils?
Oh, my God.
Why do they just want to be friends?
I died.
Oh, hello.
Oops.
Help.
Oh, shit.
I'm back.
Oh, I almost died.
Help.
I think there's...
Oh, no.
I'm dead behind the table.
Oh, that was close.
I'm washing.
All right, I'll go wash too.
Thank you.
Oh, God.
I'm feeling explosions.
I would like you to stop bleeding as much, though.
Good job.
Ruining the vibe.
Where else are they?
Oh, there's one over here, yeah.
Oh, it's all the way back here?
The explosions are adorable.
Yeah, I'm just gonna say that now.
Back rooms.
Oh, did we get it?
Yay!
I think it's a set period or you kill Wallia.
This feels very much like it's Christmas aesthetic.
I feel like it's very green.
It's so green now.
My eyes need to adjust each time.
Oh.
Maybe the back rooms really were copywritten, so this has to
be really green.
No, but the last room, the last room was yellow.
Yeah, it's really green.
I guess they redecorated, you know, they're trying to
rebrand, you know, to...
It's getting dirtier.
That's why we're cleaning it.
It must be moldy.
Ew.
If you ever want, like, a Christmas cleaning game, you
should do Viscera Cleanup Detail Santa's Rampage.
Oh, no, we did do it.
Min and I played it before.
You played that one?
It's good.
Yeah, remember, it's the one with the gore.
Yeah, and like, you know, the like the gnome body parts if
like, you know, you opened a cupboard it would they would
fall out and then get blood everywhere again I think we did.
Yeah, yeah, that was terrible.
I did not like that game Well, it's because it was like
every single we had to clean every single speck and we're
like where the fuck is the last one?
Yeah, if you knocked over the bucket or something it would
like throw blood everywhere.
Yeah, yeah, I hated hated
I finally 100% did that.
It's really your job, man.
Yeah, I'm really good at crime scene cleaner.
What was that?
What's that noise?
Oh my god, it's the spirit of Sean again!
We have Sean again!
Sean is giving us bananas from the heavens!
It's like a snack break.
What lore is this in the back rooms?
Are these the angry, restless spirits that reside inside the
hallways?
I don't understand.
It's just Sean.
Someone should run into that and see if it warps you into
somewhere stupid.
next time.
I'll go.
I'll definitely just blow you up.
It also pooped a book out, or did somebody throw a book out?
Mom wants you to read, stuffy.
Read more.
Yeah, read more.
All right, what's the last thing you read that wasn't a fan
fiction?
The Warrior Cats.
Oh.
Wait, have you actually kept up to date with the Warrior
Cats shit?
I've been reading it on stream to my viewers.
Yeah, we read it.
she she has i've seen her guys we got two stars in that one
we're we're slack in we're slacking we're slacking book it's
good we're ready for the game i hope you guys are gonna play
there's a game i'm playing a game yeah someone knows the
warrior cat's game it looks like a freaking roblox game it's
like i agree it's like an r it's gonna be an rpg hi okay it
gets to be a cat i'm very simplistic I used to roleplay
warrior cats and neopets.
Oh, like, stop.
I could marry you.
Yeah, my warrior cat name was Wild Pelt.
Wild Pelt?
Because I got it from, I got it generated.
No, you know, like, okay, no Warrior Cat website.
Oh, yeah, the Warrior Cat website.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, the name generator.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I got it from, oh, it's so pure-hearted from a sick and
twisted bitch like you.
I don't know.
I don't think you are so cute and innocent at some point.
You're so messed up and now you play apex.
Maybe you're the messed up one.
I'm the norm.
I should have a normal.
I'm the normals.
I'll do that after.
Oh, there's like seminars and cosmetics you can buy too.
Yeah, yeah.
I want to take one of the seminars after this.
They're so good.
I'm playing solo though.
So sweet.
I don't know.
some of them are relevant to yeah wait this is cute there's
a yellow face plate plate color and a Sakura suit color
mm-hmm I can be fully yellow yeah be fully yellow I can be
fully yellow but I can change the logo color they're
expensive though wait that does not look good wait I want to
see which one is it it does not look as good as I thought it
was gonna look Did you buy it?
You look like you like sneezed all over your visor.
Oh.
Ew.
That's gross.
I don't have any more sick days, guys.
I'm just admiring this lumen door here.
It's so like ambient and bright.
I know.
It's really bright.
It hurts my eyes.
Oh, this is so good.
It looks like a raw, like, shader on blender or something.
The reflection is so intense.
Actual sun POV.
Wash it down.
All right.
We'll head over to...
I feel like you should read out the lore.
Use your way.
You have, like, a McDonald's coloration going, Dogey.
Oh, like, my yellow and red.
What's the lore?
All right.
Attention.
actions of the attached list of c group scientists have been
wholly disavowed by a corporate family any subsequent
actions from the group are noted to be entirely unauthorized
by our executive team f-corp cleaners it is imperative that
you are successful in the complete purge of all materials
pertaining to their actions we value your service all right
what that was not more going on i've been i was trying to
bring the radio over to bludge and snuffy with it but you
saved her wait how do we get it what do these shapes me for
god's sake they'll run across the what the platforms it says
oh it said don't do that oh i did that already like a number
of times uh oh well i hope it doesn't pay like i hope you
don't have radiation poisoning or something now it's just
it's a suit i got a suit oh there's actually oh there's
actually a room below it if you if you run across oh wait
wait donky come and stand on this which was this one next to
me this one yeah everybody's dead That one seems okay.
No, this one seems okay.
There's a hole.
Dookie, test this rat trap.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a guy dead.
Oh, no.
Yeah, there's like a bunch of people dead down there.
Oh, shoot.
Surely it'll be fine.
No, I actually meant the one over on the side here, but you
can go down that one if you want.
Do we have to clean this up too?
Yeah, we...
Oh, my God.
This place is so dirty.
We're not going to get three stars at this rate, guys.
We're not going to get three stars.
We were too busy looking at bodies.
Barbaro.
Oh my god, Barbara.
Barbara?
I've been agreeing with my dolls.
Hannah Barbara?
Scooby-Doopy.
Wait, what?
Did you just rip this off?
Where'd you go?
How strong are you?
I've been going out to the gym lately.
Yeah.
You've been going out.
She's been doing CrossFit.
She's been doing a couple of...
She took CrossFit lessons at Off Guy.
Yeah.
See, look at, read her name, read her name, it's Barbara.
Barbara, where are you?
Oh, what's that noise?
Oh, where?
Barbara?
I said Barbara.
I want to say Barbara.
I think it's the guy that like, down below us.
Yeah, bananas.
Oh, yeah.
It's a banana orb.
I see.
It's a banana man.
It's shot again.
I see it's downstairs.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm with shot.
Oh, he does like poop out like things to clean, I guess.
Yeah.
He poops up bananas.
he doesn't the amount of items we have to pick up goes up
yeah like i'm watching the counter in the bottom of the
stuff here and then you can take out i think we're supposed
to take out like the oh it's because like i remember in the
actual back rooms uh that been to you've been to the real
back oh leak leak in the sorry in the actual back in the
sorry in the fake back rooms are not real What are you
talking about?
Are you sure?
You sound like you've just exposed like a secret government
facility.
I know.
Back rooms are...
Guys, back rooms are just like made up on the internet,
guys.
What you saw?
You never read?
What you read is just all make believe, everybody.
Uh-uh.
But like in the original back rooms, dude.
There's no panels on top of it.
So there were holes in the floor.
Oh, that was you.
Just as a heads up.
Ah!
Oh, Jesus.
What is that?
Oh, sure.
Not good.
Oh, they're like lasers.
Oh, it's- There's a lot down here.
I feel like we don't have to clean it.
Oh, come on!
If you clean it, you get, like, sigil power.
Yeah, you get the special power.
Oh, I see.
And eventually, when you go upgrades, it gives you, like,
sigil power gives you things, like, double drop.
I died.
I see you.
Help!
Oh, thank you.
Doki's got you.
Thanks.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, it's like, in the original back rooms, uh, it's just
holes on the floor.
So there's no, like, somebody's trying to save people a bit.
This is all there is to be afraid of in the backrooms is
just, like, things on the floor?
No, it kind of depends on, like, the backrooms.
It depends on where you're at in the backrooms.
Oh, we got it!
Maybe.
Is that me?
Oops.
All right, I got all...
Wait, we need more of the...
Oh, my...
What's this saying?
I keep thinking that the ambient buzzing noise is the fan in
my computer, like, breaking.
I'm like, oh, my God, what's that noise?
Wait, where the...
Oh, there's a trash can.
Is your computer okay?
Why are you...
accustomed to hearing oh there's a noise it's real no it's
really quiet which is why it was confusing and then i
realized it was the game i feel like that most computer is
always there's something it's like haunted or something i
know not maybe not doing great let it's have a good time
that's what you tell to someone that's dying they're having
a good time they're doing great guys nothing to worry about
yeah or sigil powers time 7 let's go I'm times nine.
What?
Someone's slacking.
I probably died.
She died.
I died.
I mean, if you didn't slack off, you would have been alive.
I didn't slack off.
I was alive until I wasn't.
No, no, no.
Hey, I'm doing a good job cleaning, though.
Is the floor filling with smoke?
Sorry, is the room filling with smoke?
It's, like, really misty in here suddenly.
Are we having to...
I don't...
I don't know.
What is this?
Oh!
Whoa, there's a lot down here.
What the heck?
Oh.
The orb, the banana orb is back!
Chop him!
I really like the noise that it makes.
I know.
Oh, oops.
Are you one of those people that can stick their finger in
their mouth and make like the pop noise?
No, I wish.
Can you stuffy?
No, no.
I can definitely not do that.
I would 100% try if I didn't have like swords in my mouth.
I don't even know how like to do it.
it's something i don't know yeah i don't even know how
people do it i just seen them do it they just stick their
finger like a baby and then it goes in yeah i know i know i
know i know the concept behind it i just can't do it what's
the i know the math i know the science yeah yeah try it i
want to hear try no i try what's the concept what's the
concept though maybe we can do it after you teach us i don't
i don't think so not like it's like those who it's like
those who like are acting coaches they uh they themselves
what did you do with the trash how do you are you like
swinging it bring the trash can down here please we kind of
need to bring the trash can down here this is terrible i'm
dropping it drop it it's been dropped drop it where is oh i
see it thank you dropped these dropped oh shoot oh no oh
it's really right over here though that one of the sigis
Yeah, I think the spikes weren't as good.
Oh!
Ah!
Oh, what the heck was that?
Oh, I died again.
Sorry.
I don't notice the orb's about to blow me up until it's too
late.
Me too!
I'm too busy cleaning!
We got dead bodies down on the bottom floor.
What?
Me!
Are you cleaning?
Are you cleaning them?
No, we're dead.
We're dead.
We're dead down bottom.
We need help.
Yeah, help us, please.
Oh, are you all dead?
Oh, yeah.
Where are you guys?
the the orbs that you're missing oh thank you oh there you
go thank you they were right next to you and you didn't help
them um did we miss i don't get paid to we're literally
literally a job right now our job is to clean not to revive
well you know this is why we don't want to be on a team with
you doki in your tournament because i'm doing the objective
that's true i am doing the thing showing your true color
yeah yeah i'm feeling a little i just died guys i just
killed myself what what how i don't even know but my new
name is worky hello worky i think i found out one of the
hole and i crushed myself with a great i think there is some
sort of like personal damage you can inflict Check it out.
Check it out.
There we go.
Oh, oh, oh.
Watch this, guys.
Ow.
I'm going to do a three-pointing.
Watch this.
I'm going to throw it.
Three-pointing.
Back shot off the rim.
360.
Corner shot.
Trick shot.
Bam.
First try.
Can you move it over here?
Let's, you know.
I think this game would be much improved.
Proved actually, yeah, if every time you drop one of these
metal pipes, it just did the fucking pipe falling sound.
Oh my god!
Over and over and over again.
Genius game dev ideas, like the popularity of those like
stocking game store games, except it was just like...
Wait, what's the stocking game store game?
Oh, you know, there's like movie simulator, movie store
simulator, and like farm shop simulator and grocery stores.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
What if you had like metal pipe, long day at the metal pipe
factory the game?
Can someone help me kill the banana dispenser?
Sorry, I'm doing my job.
Someone jump into it, jump into it.
I'll miss you.
Oh, shit, where'd you go?
Where'd you go?
Hello?
Oh, I'm back.
Okay, I'm back.
What happened?
What did you see?
My name is Merlin.
This is my first day of the job.
Oh, you died.
Hey, guys.
I can't wait to see.
can't wait to meet all like get to know all you guys it's my
first day yeah i'm looking forward to a long career together
oh bye-bye i hope you engage in as much fun activity as the
person before you yeah what happened what happened to the
guy before me and oh no way he had a long it's fulfilling
career but decided to spend more time with them how are we
not done we have to
I hate it down here.
There's so much.
Hold on.
I'm going to get that.
Yeah.
All right.
Hey, guys.
Hey.
Who's dead?
I'm not dead, but I'm in a lot of danger.
That'll be fine.
Just like the guy before me who retired.
Oh, my God.
Who killed the bee?
What?
I'm talking about you over there.
Wow, we're doing this!
Well, if we...
Why?
Oh my god, how am I gonna get you?
Don't worry, don't worry.
If I just throw this in, we'll be done.
No, I'm gonna kill you!
My name is Gabriel now.
Hey, Gabriel.
Hi.
Now we have more blood to clean up, because somebody pushed
me into the spice.
Wait, we have a butt.
We have blood up the bottom floor yeah we have blood
everywhere you spread it everywhere we could have been done
so much faster if you were to oh my god oh yeah i know right
like i'm so i'm so clumsy i just can't face through a giant
giant grate what are we missing oh press tab it highlights
everything you're missing you left some blood splatters in
the show oh i don't think we're gonna get over time for the
snuffy's fault everybody can agree i was trying to end it
faster you ended me faster i didn't know i didn't know you
could be easily inflicted and pressed between two large
moving objects oh my god i don't know how physics worked i
didn't know they they just mattered so much as well didn't
you just die by like squatting yourself that's true that's
true that just happened well now we know we can kill each
other yay yeah friendship oh pick up range it means you can
pick up at more Yeah, they come over.
Whoa.
Sounds wild.
Are you guys making fun?
No.
We would never, man.
Okay.
We would never make fun of you.
This is a nice safe place where nobody mocks anybody.
No.
You already, we don't have to, you know?
Have to what?
Nothing.
we just hit level five if you go to this other computer you
can now unlock your super awesome level five ability wait
wait we can double jump double jump or sigil step i feel
like is that it is that an is that a or choice i assume i
think it's an or choice no can i can you can you switch you
can swap them you can swap them okay cool yeah yeah yeah
Wait, air dashes...
But it's only in the air, I think.
But the ceiling is so low, why does it even matter?
Yeah, I don't know if I need to go down.
We'll find out.
All the way above us.
There were some areas that was like the ceilings were high
above.
All right, lore time.
Lore time.
Respected F-Corp cleaners were pleased to announce that D4
scouts have located a recent hideout of the prior members of
the C group science team.
Their assistance is requested in cleaning the lore.
location.
It's important the leadership team requests the full
description of the location in your post mission report.
While we cannot provide additional compensation for this
task, it's critical for the continued success of our
corporate family.
Guys, it's all about the corporal family, guys.
We're a family!
We don't need more money.
You agree?
You don't need more overtime, guys.
We're a family.
Where's the- Where's the trash can?
I gave them your pizza parties.
Where's the trash can?
already.
Oh, I found some.
There's two.
Here you go.
Oh, there you go.
There's some parkour.
Oh, I think we're gonna have to double jump for... You need
to be a sigil in power, though.
Yeah, you have to be...
The ladders.
Wait, what if we throw away the ladders so we can't use
them?
Oh, you can.
Wait, no, I think... Oh, wait, no, we don't need a double
jump.
It's like all the way here.
Alright, there's a dead body here.
Wait, can we... Do we get rid of the ladders?
off the ceiling don't get in the way you guys might collapse
into a red mist yeah don't be careful guys there's a giant
barrel it's gonna fall down be a shame if it crushes someone
oh jesus oh wait someone actually left blood on there
they're so clumsy oh my god how do you even leave blood up
there we're wearing hazmat suit it should all be contained
you know i'm throwing look what i can do Watch this, watch
this, watch this.
Where are you guys?
Oh, you're green.
Watch this.
Why are you at the top?
Oh my god, cute!
Oh, oh.
Oh my god!
The gear is in the crop surfing, hell yeah.
What did you do?
So jump on the barrel and then pick the barrel up and then
try and carry the barrel around.
Yeah, there you go.
Oh my god!
Wow!
Ah!
I flew, I flew.
Did you see it?
Did you see mom?
I did, I did see.
I did see.
It was a beautiful witch.
Very proud.
I noticed that that barrel made weird things happen to me
when I jumped down, so I wanted to see.
Oh, this seems very stable.
Okay, I should probably...
In my head.
We're going all the trash on the floor.
The zombie.
something where is the trash bin I hear I hear Sean again
I'm about to unleash right I think this is a lemon tree I
think so I can't be sure there are no lemon stealing where's
the room guys he's somewhere up there you have to get him
guys he's dumping so much unwarranted waste Sean will get
tired Sean will yeah silly Sean he just wants attention he
just don't give it to him don't give it don't give him
attention just enable his behavior yeah okay he actually did
just disappear yeah see that's what you do yeah yeah all
right thank you guys for the good parenting lesson of course
of course just don't give your child any attention why is
the couch with so much surface area harder to surf on the
barrel individual isn't that what happened to geoffrey
dalmer he had no attention as a kid oh my god what are you
trying to say like show i've seen the netflix show yeah He
had no attention as a kid growing up.
No, I think his dad just was like affirmative on the bad
stuff.
He like killed an animal and his dad was like, that's so
manly, son.
You're epic.
Let epic animal kill, son.
Yeah, he's like, oh, you have so much masculine aspiration.
Biology and bodily functions.
Boys will be boys.
I don't know.
That's what they did in the Netflix.
I don't know how true that is.
Yeah, this is in the Netflix show.
That's not like...
That's like, uh, what's his name?
Like a high school musical guy, right?
Played him?
Zach Efron?
Wait, was Zach Efron Jeffrey Dahmer?
I thought so.
Wasn't it him?
Is that who plays him in the movie?
I don't know.
Zach Efron?
I think so.
Jeffrey Dahmer?
Okay, I got poked.
Already?
I mean, honestly, that seems kind of fucked down there.
I'm, I'm Is it not him?
Is it not him?
Is it not?
Guys, no, Jeffrey Dome is a real person.
What is going on?
Who played him?
I thought it was Zach Efron.
Zach Efron was Ted Bundy.
Oh, Ted Bundy!
I'm getting my serial killer if I can do it.
Oh, wait, who died?
Me!
I got poked!
Oh.
Okay.
That's kind of cringe.
Kind of cringe.
Don't get poked again, your buddy.
Get poked again!
Ah!
She's not get puked again.
Wait, why are the...
These are all cleaned.
Why are they still here?
I don't know.
I think the metal thing is actually protecting, like, one
little bit there or something.
Yeah, I think so, too.
Because...
Alright, I'll go.
I'll go.
Hold on.
Oh.
You'll go?
Oh, here you go.
I got that one.
Wait, I'm trying to get the middle.
Okay, here we go.
There we go.
The sigil of power.
Oh, I died.
That sounded bad.
Can you help me?
Thanks.
Yeah, I got you.
You guys did it.
Yeah.
I'm Freya again.
Oh my god, Freya's back.
Guys.
I've resumed my previous identity.
We're like, I'm your own possible lives.
Yeah.
I don't even clean that over there.
Decent help nowadays.
I think we have to get, like, these dilute solvents and...
and dilutants and stuff on the wall too.
Do not mix.
I appreciate.
I think we've got to get away.
Oh!
Oh.
I heard that.
I heard that right behind me.
I turned around and watched you keel over.
Hello.
I'm Tenebrae.
Tenebrae.
Oh my god.
Tenebrae from Nebraska.
Epic Tales reference.
Oh.
Why did they keep putting these sigils so far up?
So inconvenient.
Oh, my God.
Please don't backrooms me.
I don't want to be backrooms right now.
Do not think about us.
No.
Did you mix it?
That's a...
I was just trying to have fun at the idol show.
Acids.
Riders like...
I like what...
Oh, I hear...
Sean!
Sean's back.
Nice.
Sean, why can't you quit us, Sean?
He's not throwing bananas this time.
He's throwing pots.
Oh, that's even more inconvenient because you can at least
pick up multiple bananas at a time.
You can't pick up multiple pots.
Yeah, good luck everybody down there.
Sean's going through a phase right now.
Going through his pot phase, guys.
No, don't do drugs!
Don't do drugs!
Well, if you're in heaven, like...
He's in the back rooms.
Is this heaven to you?
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I forgot his soul is...
He's like stuck in purgatory.
If you're in heaven, you can do drugs.
You can do whatever you want in heaven, you guys.
Don't worry about it.
What is your heaven?
There's a shotgun here.
Delete the evidence?
Why are there so many of these stinking sigils?
They're so annoying.
I know, I'm like, it's like footprints on the floor, but on
the walls.
It's like, maybe this is a giant footprint.
Walking on the wall.
Are we gonna have to face this guy later?
Come on.
Face him like G-Man.
The backroom's cleaner final boss.
Eh.
I'm curious, now on the computer, it shows like other
levels.
So I'm curious.
It does, yeah.
There's like, there's pools and stuff.
We can go on our vacation.
I wonder if we skip levels.
In my heart.
after this
oh oh there he goes right here oh oh get this one get this
one no it's the spikes oh lordy is it gonna i got this one i
can't reach it okay come on keep going yeah we're good we're
good all right you guys i'm gonna just clean the egg it's
hot it's in my head Jame, jame.
Where?
This is a big ass room.
Are they?
I'm stuck in your head.
Some of the graffiti on the side I ran too fast.
Um, can someone help me please?
I'm gonna help you.
Okay, helping.
Thanks.
Oh.
Guys, kids, don't do drugs or you'll go into the back rooms
and then you have to clean the back rooms.
Oh shoot.
Am I gonna die here?
No.
That'll be fine.
I'm bringing up more stuff to the floor.
Clean day.
Thank you.
I'm eating like a little rodent.
They're feeding me at the bottom of the bottom.
I got that one.
Where are these coming from?
Okay.
What do you mean?
Must be like up at the top.
Yeah, I got it.
I got it.
I see it.
The top is clean though.
Oh, man.
I was so close.
Oh, my eyes.
I know.
It's so green.
It's so green!
I can't stand it!
I can't adjust to it!
I feel like I get teleported into another reality for a
second.
Oh wait, do we have the double jump or whatever now or...
If you have sigil power, yeah.
I don't have it.
Wait.
Oh!
Oh, I got them.
Probably we missed a spot, guys.
She did not have sigil power.
No, I did!
I double jumped into the...
I don't see it.
Everything's like on the floor.
You guys missed a spot here.
It's all on the floor where someone died.
Oh, right?
Little tiny spots.
Oh.
Throw that shit in here.
Someone picked it up.
You gotta throw it into the bin.
Where's the bin?
Now they're both down here.
They're both down here.
Everything?
I got it.
Yay!
Oh, three stars!
Yipps!
It's a green room.
Oh, it hurts you.
Oh my god.
Hey, you got the green color.
Hey, look, a better green color.
Sam.
That's nice.
Yes, thank you.
It's green and pink.
That looks just like...
I actually better cut two-tone my suit.
You can, you can, you can, you can, like, make your visor,
like, like, low-toxic piss.
Just like Doki.
Yeah.
Sorry, I just had to come in sick for work.
I took all my sick days already.
Yeah, weaponized nozzle.
Weaponized nozzle.
I'm going to get that in, actually.
I'm going to get weaponized nozzle.
And then...
How much money do I have?
I have 2040.
I have 50% air control.
All right.
I'm looking at my upgrades.
Oh, nice.
I'll do more nozzle power.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what I'm doing.
I'm going to be an efficient cleaner.
I'm going to be made salmon.
All right, I'll check if we can do the pool.
Ooh.
Or if we have to unlock it.
Oh, yeah, we might have to unlock it.
I don't know that.
Oh, yeah.
Tile green.
That's what I am to you.
Oh, there's mint.
There is mint.
We got to do...
No, we have to do gold rating on people.
peaceful 105 ladder.
Wait, that's literally what we just did.
105 ladder.
That's literally what we just did.
I don't see which one are you talking about?
The mint color.
Mint.
That's green suit color.
No, it says mint suit color.
I don't see which one are you looking at.
The one that says literally mint.
Oh, okay, Hyland.
Alright, round two, electric boogaloo.
We're back.
Wait, what do we have to achieve here?
It's peaceful.
Oh no, no, wait, no, let's not do it.
No, no, it's okay.
We've already done this one.
No, no, I already, no, it's okay.
There's no essentials this time though, so it's just... Oh,
I don't want to do it again.
This level is annoying.
But you wanted mint color.
No!
I want to go to the pool, mom, please.
I want to go to the pool.
You can only pick one.
I didn't pick this!
Everybody stop cleaning.
Boycott, Ryan, please.
You hear the people sing?
Yeah, where is she?
Yeah, come here.
Let's go beat her with large objects.
Oh, you can.
You guys can, like, beat me up and I'll just die.
I literally killed...
I literally killed Min.
It's definitely bossy.
Yeah, but...
Well, you push me off and into the...
Into the, you know, into this thing.
I wonder if I can't...
If I get enough, like, ability to move these around quickly,
I bet you I could hit someone with it.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, there you go.
see where's the where's the door it's got to open up there
it goes oh there you the door yeah ask permission someone to
say the door to darkness all right no priority mission we
regret to announce that a B team secure site has been raided
by previously mentioned non-employee individual the site
must be clean and any scientific materials bin for archival
imported.
Unlike with the prior F-Court mission, employees are not
authorized under any circumstances to study or read any
materials.
I see your confidential proprietary information.
Failure to comply with this request may result in
termination and legal action.
We can't read?
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, there's trees here.
Oh my god, cute!
That's cute.
That's nice.
I feel like there's a whole car Oh my gosh There's a house
there's a house up there.
You can literally live in the back rooms I don't think you I
don't think you should live in the back rooms.
I wonder if the back rooms have a Wi-Fi or fiber They
definitely have fiber.
They definitely have fiber.
They must have put like some data connection in the Is that
usually like something awful and aggressive roaming the back
rooms.
Oh, there's the trash can.
Yeah, but like they got it do something when there's nobody
there, you know?
Like, they gotta provide some entertainment for them.
Are you saying that the cosmic entities need enrichment?
I think the cosmic entities might have an iPhone.
Cosmic entity?
I mean, there's PCs in the back rooms.
Like, why would you have PCs in the back rooms if you don't
have internet?
This looks like a land party.
I'm not gonna lie.
They have a land party up here.
Land at the back rooms.
I'd rather go up there.
How do we get up there?
You just do it.
I'm up here.
In the movie, so yeah, like, I never really did much
backrooms lore.
I've only really engaged with SCP.
In the movie, they said that backrooms is, like, trying to
make copies of real things and making them less and less
perfect because it's a copy of a copy of a copy.
Is that, like, actual backrooms lore or is that movie lore?
It's, it's, uh, that's how Captain Clark came to be.
Oh, wow, there's a couple houses.
in the movie i just didn't know if that's like accurate to
the overall backrooms vibe it's like scps it's okay so it
depends it depends like who's writing it i thought the
backrooms like wasn't scp no what was that oh the backrooms
wait was it not is the backrooms is sort of something pushed
me you guys was it me push you it was probably like a giant
object that i swung around oh somebody's throwing stuff at
us it's me i'm up here Look up, look up!
Look up, look up!
Oh, oh!
You're red!
Oh, it is separate.
I couldn't tell.
I feel like...
Because a lot of, like, a lot of, like, internet, like, what
are they called?
Like, the cryptics are based off of SCPs.
Cryptics?
Cryptics.
It is, truly.
That's the word for it.
Like...
I thought it was cryptids.
Or is it cryptids?
I don't know.
There you go.
English is my first language.
Oh, wow.
surfing again hold on I must I must go in an adventure oh no
it ate it oh don't worry Sean's with me guys I got I'm in
the house thank you what's in the house oh that house
reminds of that cabin game that you played oh I hated that
game was it scary or just bad it was scary oh I'm pretty
sure it was very short yeah the cabin game I mean have you
played it sorry what was it it was like a one of those
anomaly games but oh yeah but it was pretty spooky yeah got
you oh yeah oh yeah i miss i'm making these i'm making these
i'm throwing some i'm throwing some guns here they're
unregistered guys there's so much up here holy cow oh guns i
thought you said oh i lived what happened you fall you
somebody wrecked their car into the the back rooms What a
bozo.
The Cabin Factory?
Yeah, the Cabin.
I heard good things about the game just that it's just
short.
Yeah, yeah, it is good.
Don't get me wrong.
It's just really spooky.
Ooh, sounds good for Halloween.
It would be.
Oh, yeah.
Halloween's coming.
Yeah.
Oh, do you hear the new Silent Hill?
Oh, wait.
You were playing the new Silent Hill game.
Is it good?
It's really, really good.
I love it a lot.
Oh, amateurically, it's so good because it's like...
They they've so faithfully kind of like refrigerated what
like Like a UK
Guys go to the center.
There's 20 sigils in the second floor and I might need to be
res I need to be resed I think we're all dead.
Are we all dead?
No, no, no.
There's no way Lyma was still alive.
I'm alive.
I'm alive I see her.
She's cleaning right now.
I see her cleaning.
Stop cleaning.
I was trying to I was trying to kill a sigil Stop cleaning!
Why is this blue?
This is so scary!
What is that?
That one sends you, the blue one launches you.
Oh.
Is that good?
Oh no!
Oh!
I got fucked up, but it went underneath the soil so I didn't
see the edge of it.
Who's that over there that's alive?
Me?
Oh wait, how did you live, Snuffy?
Uh, I don't know.
Well, I blew red with me.
Oh, I died against him.
I think floor dipping down is screwing me over because I
can't see where the edges of the bombs are.
It's okay, Stoppy.
You guys gotta live.
Stoppy, you just gotta live.
You just gotta live.
I'm trying.
Why'd there have to be stinking?
Who is this?
Oh, God.
Sue?
Alive.
I'm Mira.
My name is Aaron.
You guys should get res now, but you left a bunch of blood.
All right, I'm taking over the third floor now.
Hey, I was up there.
And you get the second floor.
good um I love how accurate it is to a UK town it's very
very cool it looks really cool I saw someone complaining
because they were like this asset looks like it was made in
like in PowerPoint because it was like you know it was like
in a clinic and then it was like welcome to the family
clinic and it was like clip art stuff yeah but then it was
like back in the day you know that's legitimately like I
could wander into a random like small town family clinic
right now and see playing exactly like that it's that's how
accurate it is you know at least at least this little family
small business is not using ai i know i mean the game takes
place in the 90s impressive if they were yeah oh no i hate
though i hate that like like when i recently a lot of like
restaurants have been using ai to display their their food
it makes no sense yeah it's disgusting like when I order
food with like food trucks It is, yeah, with food trucks
Because I'm like, bro, you just take a picture of the food
you made.
Like it's not that difficult to do.
Your job is to cook.
Just snap a photo on your iPhone.
Upload it.
Is that mop?
No, that's not me.
Yeah, you should play the New Silent Hill.
It's really good.
I'm not playing New Silent Hill.
Are you a coward?
Yeah, she's a coward.
She's a coward.
I am.
I'm not.
it i know i i know what i am it's not in the house because i
know it i have oh my god oh my god oh my god oh okay i flew
i flew i'm sorry that scared the crap out of me i'm just
curious because like i haven't heard much about this new
silent hell game it's great they really didn't show like
anything about it until like yeah until it's like everybody
was playing it so yeah i saw negative reviews though but
it's just people saying like the They don't have the specs
for the Silent Hill game.
Yeah, no, if you...
Negative reviews because they don't have specs for it.
Like, because it's, like, very...
It's not optimized or some shit.
I feel like that's a lot of AAA gaming these days that
nothing has ever optimized.
I feel like it's just because, like, maybe things are
changing.
But that's because it's, like, really beautiful.
Like, the only thing that I noticed is that there's some
traversal stutter.
But hopefully they'll fix that.
That's just, like, you know, UE5 shit.
Is it glory?
Oh.
It's a Silent Hill game, yeah.
It's a Silent Hill game.
Yeah?
Okay, but maybe it's like imaginative.
Boy, Stubb, have you ever played a Silent Hill game?
Yeah, yeah, I've played two of them.
I played the room and I played...
There was one on the Wii.
Be careful, be careful about saying...
Oh wait, that one's good though.
Yeah.
Be careful about saying the room though, people say it's not
a real Silent Hill game.
Really?
I thought Shattered Memories was kind of a wild game, but...
Why is it not a real Silent Hill game?
Oh shit, you guys, the cabin got you guys, the cabin got me.
What?
Oh, now it launches you.
Now it launches.
Oh shoot.
Why isn't it real Silent Hill game?
Some people just say it's not.
Don't be Silent Hill game.
Oh god.
Um, which one was it?
The remastered Silent Hill 2.
No.
Oh.
I played two and three in remastered 2.
No, I think people wouldn't.
it was one of those situations where when it first came out
people were really not a fan of it and now it's like fine
what the heck how is there more i i've cleaned this thing i
fucked up i jumped oh my god stop okay so who's still i
tried to jump oh i am oh my god oh my god oh i'm the I'm the
hero!
I'm the hero!
I totally just walked into that.
I'm still on the third floor.
I kind of just stared at it, tried to jump over it didn't
work.
I'm so tired.
I'm so hooked up.
Yeah.
Okay, there might be a lot of blood now.
There's a lot of blood.
My bad.
Everyone clean up after yourself.
Clean up after yourself.
Well, my body's on the third floor, so I'm gonna head over
there.
Here, let's move this.
Yeah, the only games I played was the Shattered Memories on
the Wii which was kind of an interesting game because you
it's like an arcade game you like run a lot yeah you run
forward a lot and then the room which i don't know why that
would be considered because i only have ever played the or
i've only played those two and i watched the silent film
movie which one which one which one i don't know which one
it was it was like there was a mom and she was looking for
her daughter or something first one yeah don't watch the
other two there's i watched the newest one that came out
like, uh, I think like this year it's not great.
It's not a good set.
I like how they were like, it's a triumphant return for the
Silent Hill franchise.
I really liked the original Silent Hill.
I like the first one.
Yeah, the original Silent Hill movie.
Why am I throwing a chair?
Excuse me?
I'm here!
Are you trying to kill me again?
You were a murderer!
No!
This is just so obtuse.
She's trying to kill me, you guys.
She's reenacting the Netflix documentary, she thought.
She's...
Why is this floppy disk moving around?
The floppy disk.
The original...
Sean's back.
The newest movie was directed by the guy who did the first
movie, so I thought it would be okay.
Yeah, and he was like, we're gonna make it amazing again.
No, no.
It was all CGI.
Mostly CGI.
It was so fucking weird.
I watched it with the dragon.
and then we were like what the fuck is going on yeah i'm
just gonna bring this upstairs can someone murder sean he's
like i got everybody's gone is it even like a like campy
kind of bad though like it's like silly um i guess i i guess
if you want to see it that way but object of power oh oh
what are the containment protocols man i think this is
actually a target i have to target you have to redacted yeah
yeah it's totally redacted i want to play i want to play
more control how far are you where are you at right now uh i
saved i saved philip you saved philip totally saved him he's
doing great he's amazing he literally called me yesterday
and said i hung out with my kids and they really love me it
was his it was his last day on the job he was super excited
to go home and enjoy his retirement with his family.
No, he did.
He did.
Yeah, he did.
He definitely did.
Yeah.
Is she lying, Limo?
Is she lying?
No.
I guess you have to play the game and see.
I tried to play it.
What do you mean you tried?
And then...
You just do.
Because the video doesn't exist anymore.
I think...
What do you mean the video doesn't exist?
Oh, shoot.
Think, think, think, think.
Oh, fuck.
Woohoo!
That was fun.
Oh, there's some explosion.
Ah!
Let's just say the Steam account associated with that
doesn't exist anymore.
I'll gift it to you.
I'm not playing from the...
I'm not playing from the beginning.
Yeah, control.
I'm not replaying it.
It's a rough game to start over again.
It is, I agree.
Yeah, no, I guess I never finished Alan Wake 2 as well.
No!
Oh, no.
or like he's so good it's because it was it's it's so scary
for me too oh i didn't wonder why is it scary it's a it's
like a spooky game you get known the context about allan
wake 2 is me gushing about like a particular section that's
not scary at all so she's like wait it's a horror game i
know yeah it was so it's so fun and groovy no no it's it's
actually a horror game surprisingly So it's, I think it was,
it's definitely scary than the first Alan Wake game.
I got it.
The thing is, like, I was at like, I think like almost a
halfway point.
Who died?
Stuffy.
I'm sorry.
I tried to, I tried to Mario jump.
Anyway, you say something about Alan Wake.
It's a horror game.
It was like, I was halfway, I'm more than halfway.
And then, and then I never was able to finish it.
And my child was like, you should finish it.
I was like, I don't, guys, I don't want to replay it.
all the way and after the thing is i have to i have to
replay it on stream too because the bots for it don't exist
anymore so then so it would be weird if i'd start in the
middle of the playthrough like right uh it's really good
though it is i can i can't can't can you like like watch it
youtube like dokey bird has two items in their pocket dokey
bird oh the game told me the game told me no i don't I think
the game might be wrong.
Lie Militias has an item in their pocket.
I was picking it up on the fucking floor to put it in the
thing.
I literally just picked it up.
Dude, you gotta watch those like YouTube movies.
No, yeah, just one hour long.
No, like, no commentary played through.
You know, I might actually do that for hours too.
Yeah.
Because I'm so mad because I was about to get to the part
where I was.
where he does this performance thing wait wait wait i play
it dokey wait dokey when i play it do you want to sit in
with me i mean yeah yeah i'll sit in then i can play it and
you can just watch yeah that's true there's more people
experiencing ellen wake that makes me happy true yes
commentary
yeah why don't you even play are you playing it after
control yeah to wait until i beat the play resonant oh so
you're going control alan wake 2 right so you're doing it in
order that's good yeah that's the order yeah the actual
official game order it's yeah yeah so i think it's it's like
it's kind of like max pain i guess then quantum break then
can then alan wake 1 then control then alan wake 2 then oh
my god there's so many games yeah she knows like they're
highly ordered in a full it's basically a release order it's
not complicated i've only known this game existed since i've
seen limu do the dance segment i have no idea yeah i think
that's the best that's the whole thing that's the whole
thing but tanya's please proceed to attach coordinates a
full clean location i'm upgrading it's especially critical
to cover all objects in the location regardless of an
abnormal state or behavior additionally is our pleasure to
announced that we have initiated a full review of fcorp
employee compensation levels to be carried out over the next
14 months your work is critical to our collective success oh
we're getting compensation now guys promotion we're getting
promotion i'm gonna be purple yeah i'm gonna be purple i'm
gonna be purple purple all right i could do a couple more
i'm i'm strong we have two more unlock a newer area oh so
we'll know where we'll know what pardon my language pardon
my language
hey guys remember to check out the sloppy sisters collab
guys yeah
We're talking about what are hazing how we yeah how do we
haze in our sororities or fraternity is it a fraternity or
sorority well fraternities for guys and sorority are for the
girls I'm one of the dudes what would I do I would require
people to crawl through a series of like of tubes and
tunnels to grab things.
And whoever had the biggest horde at the end wins.
This is that monster.
Did you just copy Monster Ink University?
It's a ferret thing.
Oh.
Come on.
I can get it.
I need some help.
Just help me get this through.
I can do it.
I can't touch it.
You have tostellar.
Are you having trouble finding the hole, man?
No, I got through the hole.
I got through the hole.
There's a piggy bank.
I want to... I want to...
It's like a piggy bank.
okay what would you guys do for your raising well wait i
remember mint was show i want to have a cult in the sewers
yeah you want to have a cult in the sewers oh yeah i see
based on a real story yep of the cult at her university yeah
the cult at my university where there were ninja turtles
there oh yeah donatello donatello michelangelo i wish i
thought you you said dr Donatello twice, I thought you were
doing some sort of like, let's go in the sewer and do like
Bloody Mary with the Ninja Turtles.
Donatello, Donatello, Donatello.
Guys, be careful.
You have something Donatello, you say it to me?
Oh my god, guys, there's a pizza!
Are you making fun of my religion or?
It's like that when we said a spaghetti monster religion or
some shit.
like a different level already it does it's very different
oh yeah where are we why did they have like a like a whole
arsenal in here what is going on it's apparently nothing but
garbage we're getting rid of everything we just don't care
don't clean up after themselves oh my god rafael rafael
don't tell michael did you see did you see like the series
of of tweets about like someone found like a themed Ninja
Turtles restaurant and if you leave them a bad reply like
the Ninja Turtles yeah because no because it's like they use
AI like they use an AI voice to take orders if you call them
the people and then they left a bat like they left a one
star review at the pizza place being like I don't really
want to give my information to an AI Michelangelo And then
the guy...
And then, okay, the worst part is the restaurant and getting
review buff because apparently the owner, like, he replied
back, like, get on with the times, AI is the future.
What?
Like, as a...
As like a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle?
As a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle?
Yeah, as a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
Is it, like, his OC, or is he one of the Ninja Turtles?
There's something that's, like, sickly ironic about the
Ninja Turtles being named after, like, famous artists.
That's not mean you're just, like, AI, like, restaurant
marketing.
Don't forget to get some visual power.
We need it.
Oh, watch out.
Oh, I died.
Oh, my gosh.
There's so many now.
There's so many.
Oh, I don't know what you're going to say.
I'm safe.
Oh, my God, I died again.
Sorry.
I can't jump off.
Oh, my gosh.
There's so many.
I died again.
Oh my god!
I keep hearing you!
I'm farming mid, I'm farming mid right now!
I'm in like a really precarious area!
Okay, so please understand!
It's just gonna give you so much blood over there.
Yeah, sorry.
I'm...
I'll start cleaning this.
Come on, come on.
Yeah, she's looping.
Oh, it's fucked in here.
Down there?
No, I was backtracking a little bit.
There's no way we're getting through this.
There's no way.
We got this, guys.
I'm going to start cleaning Min's blood right now.
Again.
It's like everywhere.
She's sorry.
All me, by the way.
Holy shabby, you get on the wall.
I really...
I'm really screwed up.
Over and cheaper.
I'm glad you're only concerned about my blood and not my
well-being.
Surely there must be a mess pickup upgrade.
There's so much coffee here.
I know.
Oh, there is.
I upgraded it.
You can pick up more things.
An upgrade where you give less blood when you die.
I'll do the coffee.
I can pick up more things.
I was just hoping it was, like, you know, pick up at the
same time, like in Power Watch where you hold the button and
it, like, just keeps a bunch of things.
Oh, right.
and start cleaning.
Not power wash at crime scene.
I think I'm obsessed with that game, but like every other
like cleaning game I play now, I'm like, well, it's not as
good as crime scene cleaner.
Crime scene cleaner is just so, it does everything right.
It's just like what makes it, what the better cleaning game
is.
It has, it has like a little, like a ozone cleaner thing
that you can like choose.
Yeah, yeah.
You can choose like a voice on it and like I choose the
psychopathic robot voice.
So I'll be like cleaning another part of the house I choose
the demon boys.
Yeah, I can just hear going, ha ha ha, everything be purged.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's great.
It's really funny.
I should play that game.
It sounds fun.
It is.
It's really fun.
I didn't fit.
I only played like, I thought it was just like a one-off
game, so I played until like the cool area.
No, you have to save your daughter.
It's got like a storyline.
You got to save your daughter.
It's very compelling.
Is that a cool story?
Yeah, it's almost like really good.
Yeah, it's like, it's just just power wash but with an
actual story but with war but with a story and i like the
mechanics a little bit better yeah me too i like the one
that's like the japanese cat or something and like he's like
these my bad yeah it's trying to feel it's it's it's the
cleaner it's yeah it's a cleaner voice for the little robot
you can make it sound like you talk to a japanese yeah it
goes yeah it has it has like a little it'll be like senpai
I'm cleaning or whatever.
It's got like a pretty heavy accent on it as well so it's
really cute.
It's like a little maid cat cleaner.
Bye on the ceiling.
Zombie in your head.
In your head.
Zombie.
Oh my god, who keeps...
Excuse me.
Oh, I'm still Nantello.
Nantello, Michelangelo, Raphael.
No, we're almost done, game.
No!
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
Oh shit, I'm gonna die.
Holy shit!
We're in like a minefield.
Oh my god.
This is the worst place for us to be in right now.
It's just everywhere.
Wait, there's like a...
I got you, I got you.
There's like a shield on it.
Hi.
Hey, welcome back.
Ah, the spikes.
Okay, now we're safe now.
We can just ignore all the other stuff.
It doesn't matter.
There's like, there's shields on it now.
Yeah, just keep cleaning.
Just cleaning.
Just keep cleaning.
Alright, 2F core.
Well, there's some blood on the ground though.
I tried to do DLCs from the power wash simulators.
I did the Shrek one and I got like some PTSD from it.
Like cleaning DuLoc and it took so long to clean DuLoc
and...
Oh yeah, me too!
I think I...
I think I had a...
Oh, watch out, watch out.
I lost my shit a little bit towards the end and all I can
remember is my chat found of like a playlist or something.
And it had like, it had like a, I don't know, it was just
like this constantly repeating Chinese phrase.
And it was like, I don't know, what was it?
It was like Hong Kong Hong Kong 97, apparently, according to
my chat.
And it was just like this really annoying, like repeating
Chinese song.
And like I was putting, I put that on.
I was like, you know, we're almost done.
I'll play this on repeat until we're done.
This is a fucking mistake.
It was a fucking mistake.
Oh, yay!
We got gold.
Oh, here you go.
I think we're promotion bound.
Let me see the song.
Yeah, this is the song.
This is the song I got for you.
I'll put it in the collabs channel here.
I can play this on YouTube.
Yeah, Hong Kong 97 music for one hour.
Hong Kong 97.
Oh, I know this song.
I know the song, yeah!
I was cleaning Duloc to this for like an hour.
And then I was also humming the like the Welcome to Duloc
song to myself and forgetting the lyrics.
We got new terminal thing.
We got new...
Yippee!
Why is the back rooms vibrating?
Anyone?
Nice.
That's a cleansing anomaly.
I don't know if we'll find out together, I guess.
Yeah, maybe it's like it cleans for us.
I would assume so.
All right, I think we after this next one, we get to unlock
a new area.
I could at least power through until the new area.
Oh, wait, this is a boss, but I believe in...
We'll speedrun, we'll speedrun.
Whoa, who is...
Maximum priority cleaning requested.
Reports indicate that the attached coordinates are the only
location related to her exacted that remain in a
non-precinct state.
Please take an abundance of caution and know that you are an
irreplaceable member of our corporate family.
I don't really think that's true, right?
No, by accepting this task, you agreed to this about all
knowledge and experiences related to your work, including
but not limited to dimensional tunneling, null zero, and
sigil-based quantum encoding.
Are y'all ready?
Yeah.
You won't let me change my color.
Oh.
What the fuck was this?
What?
You hate my swag.
You hate the rising texture.
Who invited this clown?
I think if you guys like my look, it's similar to the Gina
Dra's snuffy collab bag.
W.W.
Yeah, yep, yep, yep.
Oh, this is a boss fight, guys.
You get yourself a bag.
Yeah, this is a boss fight.
A boss fight?
Wait, really?
We must get sigil power to break the shield so we can kill
the boss oh there's a boss yeah look at the big egg right of
you it's an orb oh my god it's a big meatball big meatball
sigil power is required have you guys played a new halloween
game yet no halloween game like the movie or the game like
the holiday no there's no it's like dead by daylight except
it's halloween well it's like friday the 13th too as well um
like i was so sad to because they removed the the sex option
they removed the sex option which is so yeah like you know
how in in like slasher films there's always teenagers having
sex and stuff because we're gonna die or just because
they're sinners or whatever and they had sex yeah so in the
game yeah so you can go into a closet power ups by banging
someone in the closet and they removed they removed it
because the implications you can play a very old man well
yeah they removed it because they got to make him an
exception to the rule and especially because the character
is they've decided to use the face of the actual actor who
played the character in the movie so he looks like the real
person and you can just like cuddle up and and get down and
dirty in the in the closet with you know actual game
teenagers which is i'm so upset that they finally included
the most epic game mechanic and they slapped it so bad like
why did you not think about that after day one they took it
out characters be able to have sex except let's model them
after real people and have their ages very great it's really
funny because Loomis can do everything that the teenagers
can do including like riding a bike so you've got this like
60 something year old man like fucking booking it on a on a
you think people can't ride bikes anymore to say what the
hell but he's he's riding it like a teenager you know you
know like how a teenager rides a BMX or something like they
fucking It's great.
No, he's young at heart, lives.
Yeah.
He still has his wings.
That's a lot of orbs.
I have sigil power.
I'm going in.
I'm shutting it down right now.
One sigil down.
I got duck.
Whoa.
Wait, like inside?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
There's like...
Oh, okay.
Oh, shoot.
Watch out.
Oh, watch out.
Whoa, watch out.
Whoa.
They're everywhere.
But watch out.
Watch out.
Wait, that was you playing.
You can double jump and stop, you guys.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I'm still...
You have the sigil power.
I got...
Turn off the song.
Sorry, guys.
You're so...
You're so good.
Are we fighting it?
I think we're supposed to fight the boss, though.
Oh, my God.
I'm attacking the entity.
Clean him.
Not now, Johnny, not now!
He's been a dirty boy.
Oh, whoa.
I don't, am I doing something?
Oh, he's getting cleans, he's getting cleansed.
If you're cleaning up, it makes cleaning noises.
Look at him, look at his little spiny body in there.
He's so small in there.
Am I hearing your dog?
Or is it the three dog?
It's not your dog!
Okay.
Oh, he does not want to take a shower guys oh my god in my
lap come he upset he's very upset he could hear the cat oh
we can't no we can't is your is your cat like is he what
what are you trying to ask what are you trying to ask what
are you trying to ask well you're that your other cat's
inbred so i'm so Oh, that's so mean.
Why is that mean?
I'm just curious.
I don't know because I thought you had a thing for inbred
cats.
I mean, I can't lie.
It's not like I, you know.
I don't understand what the like, are we referencing
something?
Her other cat's inbred.
Yeah, my other cat's inbred.
He might be.
I don't know.
They don't know.
I know she told me.
They don't know where he came from.
But now you know it's inbred.
No, it's my new cat.
My new cat.
Okay, well, she knows her other cat was inbred.
Yeah, I don't know if he is, if this one's inbred or not.
He could be.
Okay, what size is he showing?
What size is he?
What size is he not showing?
I took him to the vet today and they were like, he's a very
particular boy.
Or like peculiar boy is what they called him.
They were like, oh wow, he's doing something.
interesting things like what like wait wait wait no he
started juggling they gave him some toys and he just the way
he plays with them is a little odd i think yeah detail
specifics um he learned today that he really likes spring
toys and he'll like take them and carry them around in his
mouth and then like do like a backward shimmy with them
that's cute he's a dog Yeah, he's like a dog.
He is like a dog.
Yeah.
I heard a cat though.
Oh shoot.
Spikies.
Because they like also live with a dog too.
You might've.
Yeah.
Oh, who died?
You guys.
That's me.
My blood.
I see you.
I see you in the corner there.
I might have got my.
That's you in the spotlight.
You might be wondering how I got there.
Yeah, you might be wondering how I met your mother.
Oh shoot.
I almost died reviving you.
Is somebody whispering?
No.
What are you hearing, stuffy?
I don't know.
Somebody whispering.
Wait, but Lama, have you played that?
What do I have?
I have a shiny...
No, I just, I experienced like most of it through clips and
they were really funny.
Like I saw one guy who was like dedicatedly basically like
role playing as Limus and he was like, he was like riding
around on the motorbike like, Michael, Michael, stop it.
Michael, stop it.
Michael, stop.
Yeah, I saw that one too.
It was Halloween together.
It'd be fun.
Attack the entity!
I'm attacking the entity!
Me too.
I'm parkouring!
I'm attacking the entity!
He's basically good.
I'm parkouring again!
Why are you parkour?
Yeah!
Oh, I was jumping over the laser beams.
Stop it, Michael.
Stop it.
I'm cleaning him!
Escape!
Oh, you guys, it's like...
Oh, no, no, no.
Reach the safe room!
Sorry.
I died!
Don't look back, don't look back!
Oh, shoot.
You keep going.
I'm Susie now.
Wait, I have 30 seconds to get there and it put me all the
way at the beginning?
This is messed up.
Wait, they... Someone has to make it.
Someone has to make it.
One of us has to make it.
Oh, no, I'm so far back.
Oh, I didn't...
Hi.
What's up?
Are you guys at the safe row?
I'm gonna ride this computer.
Yeah.
We were okay.
Wait, oh, I died again.
Don't worry, I can make this.
I'm Link!
I'm also dead.
I'm also like super dead.
I'm not gonna make it.
Oh shit, I'm not gonna make it.
Yay!
I also liked watching people like ride on the bicycle and
then like do trick spins into non-stop.
knocking Michael down it was really this game sounds awesome
that's what I'm saying it's really funny to fuck around with
with friends it's like not a good game but it's a funny game
the Halloween oh man why couldn't we have played this as the
game but we could oh yeah because mechanic they removed
you're all true true no we got play this when you're all
recovered and also I have a tournament in two days I'm
stressed out I need a clean all right Oh do you stress clean
as well?
I stress clean.
When I get mad I clean.
Yeah, me too.
We got a new level.
I don't stress clean IRL.
I stress clean virtually.
I don't like that.
I do both.
Oh, this one's nice.
Oh, right.
I forgot about the seminars.
Let's go over like what if I do.
Oh, yeah, I forgot about those too.
Oh, I forgot about that as well.
Well, it's too late.
And cosmetics.
Waterfall development.
What the fuck?
There's what do they?
Can jump out of water when near the surface?
surface can swim faster I think I know what's coming next oh
it's a pool pools open are we going are we going to the pool
I'll see let me see where we go now I should have an air
control actually I'm sorry I'm so sorry guys it might not be
the pool guys no it's not the pool where are we going
because the chapter is called a drift priority with mission
an f-corp cleanup team we'll just try one we'll try one and
see all right we'll skip the one i could do i could do one
one last one last job guys oh this is no this is not the job
this is not the pool wait wait maybe it's maybe we just have
to turn in corner yeah maybe we'll turn corner there's like
a pool right there yeah yeah it's right why did you just run
around a circle I don't think there's a pool.
Wait, wait.
Johnny, you smell bad.
What?
Ooh, you smell like poopy.
Oh, is that your cat?
Are you talking about your cat?
Yeah, he's in my lap.
He smells like poop.
Your cat's name is Johnny.
Yeah, his name is Johnny.
I got really confused because my editor's name is Johnny and
I'll this is weird why do you think my cat johnny is there
like a reference it's metal gear of course it is oh there's
a guy in metal gear that just shits himself all the time i
love his name johnny yeah his name is johnny where are we
that's so funny that he smells like poop then yeah he smells
like i think it's because there's poop stuck on his butt
there could be and he sat in my lap with He sat on your lap.
Aww.
He's a baby.
He's just a baby.
He doesn't know.
Aww.
I think he was.
Here, throw them at me.
I'll take them.
Yeah, throw them at me.
Could be marking you.
Throw them at me.
I wish you could, like, touch the trash to the things and it
destroys them.
Wow!
It's like, if I touch it, it works.
So we just have to, like, smear our bodies all over it and
grab everything.
Just like Johnny.
Could I like run this into trash and have it work?
No, that's what I was just saying.
I wish it did that.
That would be good.
Especially because I removed the penalty for moving with it.
So I could have just like zoomed all over the place,
scooping stuff up.
Yeah, I tried it in the first level and realized you can't
do that.
Yeah, same.
Lame.
I'm throwing some trash out on the floor.
Clean up all those.
No, stop.
Oh, it's going to take time.
It's like a time.
What time is it?
It's not time.
take a while we have a lot of trash in this one tiny room
you know what i believe in limo to take care of this no fuck
she's sick and you're still gonna put it on your shoulders i
just decided one thing i'm delegating who made you the
delegator um i did i this is my lobby I think we should have
a cool Yeah, we don't even have a union We don't even have a
swimming pool This is like Yeah, we were promised a swimming
pool There were budget cuts There were budget cuts We were
promised a swimming pool And it's just This is really
embarrassing Yeah, but there's still time There's still time
for To get a swimming pool It's okay I have an idea Mint
leaves and makes a lobby And I'll go join Her lobby And you
guys stay here works every time wait how did we finish this
level so fast it's a baby level what oh look wait
investigate the odd signal what's that this it's an odd
thing hold on i'm coming through i'm coming it's right here
oh wait what hello this is fcorp cleaner hello is there lore
in this yes he has i've been reading the lord the entire
time do you not be listening to her sorry i'm i'm weird some
part of the study i've never seen before we We were chased
by something and ended up down here sometimes.
You guys want to hear Johnny?
Ducks.
Ducks are...
They're ducks.
Oh, I hear Johnny.
Aww.
That's cute.
Oh, baby.
Oh.
But Johnny makes me feel so at home.
Oh, what do we do?
What do we say?
Um.
Oh, look back.
Go look back.
Don't look back.
Oh, shoot.
I was playing with my cat.
Oh, my God.
To the pool.
Oh, no.
Oh, the pool.
Where the pool?
Wee.
This is nice.
I'm in the pool.
Wait.
Oh, no.
There's the pool.
It's like an intermission.
I get it.
That's fine.
That's cute.
Oh, wait.
There's a new suit pattern.
Yes.
Yay.
Wait, wait.
This might not be one last job.
This will be the one last job.
Oh, why?
Why?
You can't say no.
I'll do the pool level.
Come on, guys.
This is everything.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, my God.
It's huge.
It's humongous.
This is the lobby.
Oh, this is the lobby.
Oh.
Oh, cute.
I like how we moved all of our employee upgrade stuff into
this place.
so fun.
I like that.
I'm going to grab jump out of water, Pyro.
I feel like I might need that.
I'm stuck in the water.
I'm going to get patterned.
Oh, I'm in the water.
Wait, you're swimming.
Look at you go.
How do you get out?
Oh, uh-oh.
Wait, you were supposed to... Wait, oh, no.
I know.
I've been strange.
What happened?
Hello?
Oh, you should buy the upgrade that lets you jump out of the
water.
Oh, you have to go, yeah, through the ladder otherwise.
There's an great to let you get yeah yeah can i drown i'm
gonna check i'm checking wait why is my pattern how do you
get the pattern to work did you did you change the color of
the pattern because it starts at the same color as the suit
oh there you go i got it wait how do i get out of here
there's a ladder yeah oh okay never mind hardly is this in
the movie oh it's horrible looking oh my god the swimming
area I don't think there was a swimming pool in the movie.
I think it was mostly just the actual, like, where we were
before.
It's just the back...
Well, they're planning on making a sequel to the back room,
so maybe...
Maybe they'll add this pool.
I mean, there's, like, multiple rooms in the back rooms, but
everyone always thinks about the back rooms.
How the fuck do I select a mission?
Where's the mission computer?
Wow, I'm exploring.
There's so much to explore here.
It's, like, in the...
By the other computers.
for this one no that's the hazard front rooms oh there you
are found it are you guys ready mm-hmm all right one last
job everybody one last one watching snuffy struggle to get
out of the water I feel like a baby holy shit there's so
many ducks and why is there blood nobody could die in this
area come on let's be real but nobody died from that fall
nobody died oh did that like actually hold on hold still
okay oh yeah you do flinch wait what's that sound oh wait
what's going on up there if you toss large objects of people
they actually flinch okay hold on wait actually wait Yeah,
you did it, though.
There you go.
Oh, wait, yeah.
All right.
We're out here in the pool.
Okay, here we go.
Pool time.
Wow.
Oh, this says my name is Randall.
Some of these ducks are glowing.
Wait, hold on.
I'm reading Randall.
this hole this is randall's hole what randall's hole that's
what it says oh blimey upstairs oh it is my name is randall
yeah this is my hole no that is this hole right here hold on
i want to come look at your hole give me his presenting wait
hold on four i am a hole my name is randall i am a he's a
hole yeah i can't carry him any further goodbye buddy i love
you this is depressing my name is rand oh my god look ikea
shelves my name is rand i am a hole i am a hole two there's
a flicking calic set up there two way out two out way out is
right oh my name is ran i am a whole i am a whole we'll take
forever get that one last get that one last i can't carry
him any further goodbye buddy sean is back sean has followed
us oh no it's mud orbs kill the mud orbs they're spreading
dirt everywhere that's disgusting i don't think they're i i
don't think it's mud i think they just burst into ducks when
you kill them they burst into ducks yes they do yeah muddy
ducks too muskina this is trevor he hits his head i can't
carry him any further goodbye buddy i love you wow whoa yeah
i was looking at that depressing it is kind of depressing
maybe he should have worn his non-slip shoes and then he
would be fine maybe he shouldn't have ran at the pool yes no
running at the pool rule number 101 no running what if he's
being chased by like unknowable horrors uh well he didn't
include that in this part yeah he should have wrote that
down so he was it should have been like he wasn't uh he
wasn't breaking the rules he was simply chased by unknowable
horrors yeah yeah yeah there are exceptions you know if he
filed his if he filed a complaint uh oh shoot guys i'm
scared my favorite things to do at a train station is watch
people run past old and no running signs What is that?
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
I was just executed.
Holy.
Oh my god.
Everybody's dead.
Oh, it's gathering up the ducks.
Oh my god, death by ducks.
It like, it homes.
It's like a homing thing.
It's crazy.
Help.
Oh, I'm alive.
I'm alive.
Oh.
I'm on the lower floor.
If you can revive.
revive me for days.
Oh my God.
I'm trying to get it.
I'm getting ready.
I'm preparing myself for apex in two days.
I got it.
Please revive.
Where are you?
Guys, we're such a good team guys.
I died, died.
I'm no goose.
What?
Okay, not gonna lie.
These shit ducks.
Therapy?
Disgusting.
I'm goose.
Talk to me.
There's shit ducks.
No, look at them.
Look at the brown ducks.
What shut duck are you talking about?
Yeah, clean the shit duck and then like put it And then you
can pick it up.
No, you...
Really?
Oh.
Clean the shit duck.
Oh, you're right.
You have to clean it.
Ew.
Yeah.
Tidious shit duck.
I don't like it.
He's a dirty boy.
It's just like your cat.
I know.
It is just like my cat.
You're pressing yourself.
It's very relatable.
Yeah.
Maybe he'll have less ammo if we get rid of the ducks.
Oh, true.
He was picking up the ducks from the area, yeah.
Yeah.
so we just have to throw away all the ducks throw away the
dog oh all right i'm reloading i'm reloading
you're more oh it's not clean yet that's it will do like
little when the ducks are clean yeah this is a good oh uh
more ducks and coming duck shitters coming in oh i'm too far
oh Duck shitters.
I'm killing him!
Oh, there's so many walnuts.
They do.
Oh, there's a donut walnut.
Ew, it's getting it all over the wall.
It like smears it.
Yeah.
Oh.
Duck clean.
The orb, like, smears dirt everywhere, and then, like,
explodes into ducks, which then also smears dirt everywhere,
and you have to clean them.
Otherwise, they become projectiles, which seems just ass.
Yeah, great level.
So many legs to this.
that's probably the new the new thing though like as in like
the one that was spinning up bananas that's gonna be the
thing now so enjoy your shit ducks i'm actually surprised
there was like a throwing ducks and not hitting them inside
it's because they were inside uh bins so i was just throwing
the pins oh someone you throw a calyx in the pool come on
what don't throw a calyxes in What's a calic?
What's a calic?
It's an Ikea shelf.
Oh.
Oh, you know the Ikea shelf by name?
Our besties?
Like they made, no, they made, they made a mod.
Oh, jeez.
Oh, I died.
But they made a mod and put one in the Skyrim.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, thank you.
Oh.
Where is it coming from?
Oh, there.
Right here.
We got him.
Easy.
All right.
We just got to get rid of all the duck.
here where i want to see there i threw it oh my god
heisenberg yes heisenberg oh where'd he go i think i think i
killed him oh my god there's more ducks back here no there's
still my name dokey bird has three items in their pocket um
i just picked up the duck i love how this game tattles on
you it's so funny uh la malicious has an item in their
pocket i literally just It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Tell that to the game.
Yeah, yeah.
The game says...
No!
He's a hole!
I Ole.
He's just celebrating.
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, over there, yeah.
This tiny little stain right here.
Yay!
I'm honestly shocked that it wasn't a three star.
I thought that was pretty productive.
I thought that was pretty darn good.
I think it's because we all...
dying to the dust wow there's an f-core rate ranking yeah
we're really really fast like a speed red whoa yeah model
you employee no wait we were like 50 uh 50 seconds away
though from gold star oh look how many points i got a whole
minute yeah wow oh with that mvp maybe you should play uh
Friday, Friday's tournament.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, we were working so good together.
This was actually all practice for you to aim properly.
Yeah, we were aim training.
Oh, I see.
It was pre-warm up.
We're pre-gaming.
What's the one with the water?
Let's see, jump out of the water.
Oh, Ken jump out of the water.
It's on the seminars.
I like how Mint's upgrading us if we're going to do a part
two of this game.
Oh, well, you know.
We're hoping for next time, man.
You never know.
Man, I mean, you love this game so much.
Let's play this game again.
Wait, I bought my suit and everything.
Like, I spent...
I mean, to be fair, we don't want to waste that, honestly.
We don't want to waste the suit that you bought, the money
you invested already.
Yeah.
It's true.
We'll definitely play again.
It was fun.
I like these games.
had a good time thank you it's just like it's like power
wash simulator multiplayer but we're just in the back rooms
wait wait wait can you guys wait this is gonna be freaking
awesome you guys want to see something sick yeah oh do it do
it do it do it she's gonna prop surf on a surfboard oh yeah
wait wait wait he's stuck i can't i can't oh mediocre
You guys who does the best serve?
Yeah, I'll go.
Who does the best serve?
You guys try.
There's other ones up there.
I'll be the judge.
Oh, oh.
Dang it.
Crash.
Oh, Miz doing it.
Oh, she's getting airtime.
It's me.
I'm going.
Yeah, I'm doing it.
She's getting airtime.
I'm doing it.
Yeah, me too.
Me too.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, bye.
Crash out.
No, I'm doing it.
I'm doing it.
This looks like a Disney movie.
ride i love it you guys look adorable up there oh my god i
died oh my god she surfed too close wipe out it's fine i
didn't want to be on the surfboard anyway i wanted to be on
the watermelon tube hey you guys are good at it what the
heck stuffy come on you just got any practice stuffy
There's like absolutely no resistance whatsoever.
The game's just like, yeah, let's do it.
I killed you.
Lymu, you're next.
No, go away.
We got it.
Don't believe me.
I'm sick.
There was a freak accident at the pool.
Oh my god, I still can't get out of the water even though I
have that upgrade.
Joust.
He gets a jousting of it.
Oh my god!
Yippee!
I got too cocky.
I started going vertical.
Wait, I'm going.
I feel like we're like on a magic carpet.
I know, right?
I can show you the world.
Oh my god!
It's so horrific.
I'm just like watching you guys and when I watch somebody
like lose momentum and just my heart is like, it sings.
watching i'm coming i'm coming down for a graceful landing
you ready here we go oh my god like a helicopter oh don't
keep don't keep coming oh my god don't land on me oh my god
libu could have the flu and not sleep for three days and she
could land a plane emergency the most reliable sloppy sister
yeah incredible this is not at one percent power is this me
is this me is that yeah i know which one's me i know which
one's me with that wait can we can we do like uh um the
weekend at freddy's oh weekend at burn yeah
Hey guys, it's me!
I'm here, part of the Sloppy Sisters!
And I'm Doki Bird, I love Apex Legends!
Oh, that's so scary!
Ew, what are you doing?
Doki's dead body!
Oh my god, she's twitching!
Oh no, it's doing the crotch thrust again!
Do it for me!
more but they only they twerk when they're together like
magnets it's like they just can't help it look at them go
yeah they're like trying to reach for each other this is so
beautiful it's like a love story so baby just say yes i'm
going to bed i'm going to bed before we go before you go to
go to bed lima what should everybody check out everybody
should check out the sloppy sisters merch drop it's ending
on friday the 25th yeah you should check it out go look go
look at it it's really pretty there's lots of high quality
merch and you can support us and that would make us happy
yeah guys guys join our fraternity yeah join our fraternity
guys yeah check it out yeah get it and don't miss out.
Don't be late for class.
Yeah, don't be late for class.
Do you imagine not having your uniform?
It's very embarrassing.
If the teacher's not here in 10 minutes, we get to leave.
That's true.
That's the law.
But thank you guys for playing.
Thank you guys for watching, guys.
Thank you for watching.
Thank you, Snowfie.
Are you continuing to stream?
Halloween, guys, next game.
Oh, yeah.
Let's all have sex in the closet.
Oh, we got really quiet.
Can we like, can we like download a previous version of the
game?
Like, yeah, somebody's gotta have like a mod pack.
Yeah, right.
They download the mod and like bring the sex mod.
Bring it back, bring it back.
Okay.
Oh, we can make it, you guys.
Bye-bye.
Thank you, guys.
Bye, you guys.
Bye, Snowfie.
Snowfie, are you continuing your stream?
Are you going to go read Warrior Cats or something?
Yeah, I'm not, yeah, I'm just, I'm going to continue for
just a little bit.
Okay, I'll raid you in a second.
I'll raid you in a second.
All right, I'll see you guys.
See you guys.
Bye.
Good night, guys.
Good night.
I'm just gonna hear
Guys, I'm so sleepy today Sorry if I was like low energy I'm
so tired I'm so sleepy I think I'm gonna be so sleepy Up
until my birthday I'm not gonna lie Because every day is me
like Prep prep prep prep prep prep prep prep Until then
until then then yeah here we'll do it we'll play it on this
song ha ha even though summer's over i need that gallon of
coffee you got there me too
i hope you can get some rest soon next week thanks guys for
the collab i had so much fun i hope you guys did too i hope
you guys did too Where's the Sloppy Sisters merch link?
Oh, I'll get it.
Pre-order!
Well, you don't have to get the bundle.
Hold on.
Oh, hold on.
Collaborations.
Sloppy Sisters.
Valerius, thank you so much.
Oh, a sloppy collection here.
Spell here, clear.
And pain.
Your iPhone slippers came in today, thank you!
Yeah, I'm kind of glad that I had a collab today because my
brain is at like minimum power.
Your energy is as low as your social credit right now.
My social credit?
What does that mean?
Huh?
We will look kawaii in the cardigan.
You will look so kawaii.
Oh!
Oh, it's the song.
So...
Minus 50,000 veto credits!
No!
Johnny won't stop bothering me.
He keeps asking for food sooner and sooner and sooner.
I'm saying, you don't have to be patient, little man.
You gotta be patient.
I can't feed you right now.
Your food, your dinner time is in one hour.
You just noticed a banana on me.
I just, I had this on my head because I'm low, so random.
And then they're helping to be bananas in the game.
So, maido minto.
Saitzu.
Maple Saitzu.
Thanks for joining our month.
He's very part... No, it wasn't particular.
I got the raw... I think they were like, he's very peculiar.
No.
Hey!
Welcome back, Jonathan.
Welcome back.
He like sits in my lap for two seconds and then he's a silly
guy, though.
And you're so silly are you hungry you have a dog and a cat
body i do binto you're so crazy i know oh my gosh what other
person puts a banana peel on their head that's like so
random surely surely lampio look back your little eyeball is
so cute the profile picture no need a cat emote we should
what I have to switch out an emote, though.
Hmm.
I feel like all of my emotes are used.
I feel like a lot of them are used.
Maybe some of the older ones can be switched out.
How do you unlock more slots?
You don't.
I've reached the limit.
Basically, you would unlock more slots usually by getting
more members, but I've reached the limit, so...
The bowl by...
I guess that's...
People use that when I sipy, but...
We do have two box emotes.
We must have two boxes!
Yeah, that's the one I was looking at, fake neat.
Shall we all wear banana hats to the next convention?
If you wish.
All Ibu will be very easily identified a hat stealth and
sneak yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes YouTube has cat
emotes by default well what do they look like what do they
look like are they lovely isn't she lovely isn't she a kitty
girl is it this one
VTuber!
The ritual!
Oh yeah, the cats in the boxes are very cute.
They look enough like Johnny that I think it's okay.
Complete my ritual.
Oh, they're very cute.
Hey!
What am I hearing?
Hmm.
I think you could get rid of one of those But one is sad and
one is like Mega sad Oh, I'll figure it out Don't worry Not
stinking Don't need to be hurt I feel like I'm hearing him
chomping
It's fine I'm so sleepy Thanks for the collab you guys Thank
you, thank you Had fun I was like I hope you guys did too.
He's back.
Jonathan, what do you have to say?
What was that?
Speak.
Oh, no.
That's so pathetic.
What else?
What else do you have to say?
He's leaving.
Goodbye.
He's grabbing, he's about to spit some sick boars!
I just realized you couldn't hear me.
He has like, he's like wimpers, he just kind of makes noise,
you know.
But he does this when he's, when he wants food and
attention.
He's kissing us goodbye.
No, he's still here.
Welcome back.
You want to get in my lap again?
Okay, here we go.
Yeah, he chirps and he honks.
What are you doing?
Sorry.
I feel like so recently, Johnny has just been a ruckus in my
streams.
Right?
No, don't eat that.
He, like, gets in my lap and goes, meh, meh, meh, meh, meh,
meh, and then leaves.
And rinse and repeat.
It's cute!
You love him!
Oh, quiet.
What?
Yes, Jonathan?
Say your peace.
He was eating it.
You're not speaking anymore.
Ew.
These are very stinky sounds.
These are very disgusting sounds.
stinky stanko sounds nasty nasty nasty he's trying to eat
you yeah very wet all right let's try one last time oh wait
did he go never mind he left he left he left he left he's
bold as as both the vet and the shelter described him as
Very much all confidence, no brains.
Yes, you.
Yes, you, little Johnny.
He's back.
Because he wants me to feed him.
I want to talk to you guys a little bit.
That game was fun.
But I didn't expect to play two cleaning games.
In, you know, in two days.
My maidly duties never end.
Some of us could use that confidence, I agree.
I made maxing.
I've got, I made maxing.
Oh my goodness, oh my goodness.
He tripped into my lap.
I am a natural.
Thank you for noticing.
Oh, but Doki picked this game, so she's the one who wanted
to clean.
Come on, come on, Johnny.
Lay down Hmm
I could use that no brain Shut up leave me alone But yeah,
that was fun.
I like that one I actually I did take Johnny to the vet
today they die.
Okay, so one thing that's been He's so disgusting is
sometimes he sneezes and like big giant boogers come out and
um i took him to the vet i was like i i think he has asthma
and he doesn't have asthma he has a a little upper
respiratory infection my poor guy my poor little guy has a
little upper and some other stuff that they were like okay
well we'll try and handle this Yeah, so I got him some
medicine that I have to give him when I feed him.
Yeah, the Vexbo illness.
He didn't even go.
Did you go to Vexbo and he didn't tell me?
You?
Did you go and you didn't say anything?
And you didn't invite me?
Yeah.
This is why he needs to eat all the time.
It's true.
Yeah.
You're on a secret mission.
T-F-T-I.
Why is it when you guys meet at conventions, you don't
invite me?
You don't have a Luigi board or nothing.
What's up with that?
Europe dies.
Why don't you have a Luigi board?
And you say, Beat Phantom, are you here?
and then you bring snacks and only for me we summoned you in
Fumo format I saw that I saw that and then it had a little
board that would a little like sound board that would be
like that would be like hat done you don't answer my calls
I'm a very busy lady Fuminto had a long That's not the way.
The Luigi boards are like opening a public lobby for ghosts.
Yeah, but...
You could just say like...
Be a little aggressive about it.
Be a little aggressive.
I still don't quite remember what you said to me during the
Fluminto.
What do you mean?
I said...
What are you talking about?
I said Shimapan is the best, baby!
Merch idea.
Mint Phantom Ouija Board.
Maybe.
I feel like though some people would be a little nervous
about that.
What if it's not just me coming through?
What if it's... What if it's...
What if actually... I don't want to risk having some other
ghost coming in because and like, well, you rang.
True.
Good luck getting through Hasbro.
They own the Ouija.
They do?
I thought he was a Mario, bro.
You don't want one Pazuzu.
Shima, shima, shima.
Yeah!
Fuminto!
Was very helpful for my Fuminto at Afkai.
She gave my Fuminto great advice on how to be a stronger
Fuminto.
I see.
Wait, so they're conspiring?
That's a horrifying thought.
You must keep them just like every Minto plush must be kept
in...
It must be put in its place.
Kind of like an Annabelle doll, you know?
We should lock her up.
Throw away the key.
Runa, thank you so much for the red!
Hello, hello!
What if it's put in a vacuum bag?
Whatever works, whatever works.
It's always fun when you haunt me, Minto.
I do be doing a little bit of haunt.
I do it with a cook and I do with a haunt.
I do with a clean and I do with a haunt.
Mine is in a glass cabinet for now.
And do you appease her?
Do you do the ritual every day?
I guess you have to thanks for the gift.
Thank you, thank you.
Now we need a Fumo-sized mint box.
Way back, thank you!
Dargo, thank you!
Wait, a Fumo sized box.
Wait, like the one for the, for like the little plushie?
My Fumo's wearing the Doki Dad shirt and my Orca helmet.
The fact that she can wear the helmet is kind of insane.
She's really ginormous, huh?
Mine's in gay baby gel.
Lance, thanks so much for the vibe, get there!
She's very big.
I have multiple gay baby jails and the bigger ones go into
the big jail.
Bigger than the real mid though.
That's not even... How?
How is that?
That's not even true even a little bit.
I put mine next to my cat's bed so they would be friends but
my cat does not care about her i gave i gave johnny evil
momo so every time i see matara she gives me like a million
momos and i was like you know what evil momo needs to be put
to work and so i gave one of the evil momos she gave me to
johnny and he's obsessed he would he was going he was
picking evil momo up and carrying him around in his mouth
and tossing him into the air and pushing him everywhere the
guy has like millions of holes now my name is johnny every
time you say that i look up are you my cat are you biting
evil momo
i'm implanting memories into your brain i'm implanting i'm
implanting uh your uh your desires bite evil momo bite evil
momo bite Evil Momo.
Every time he goes after him, I'm like, yeah, kill that.
Kill that guy.
Your Oshi and your cat are now obsessed with your nemesis.
I don't think Johnny cares about Matara.
He only cares about evil Momo.
He doesn't even know, well, he does know who Matara is,
but...
Oh, to be an evil Momo carried by Mint Cat.
I don't think you'd want that He really does have a lot of
holes And saliva on him Is he a vocal kitty?
Oh my god He doesn't shut up He doesn't shut up Ever
What's he saying right now?
He's not here But if he were, he would probably say Hey
there I don't know if you've noticed, but my food bowl is
empty Please follow me so I can show you Big emergency.
Food bowl.
Empty.
Please restore food to the bowl.
Or there will be imminent danger.
No.
Everything will explode.
You know I know I'm a monster.
I'm a monster.
I even gave him a little snack before stream.
How could I do that?
I tempted him.
temptation i can't believe that i he was he's starving and i
just i tickled a little bit of food in his face now he
hasn't eaten in like five minutes it's craziness
i'm so ready for my birthday to be over i'm ready for my
birthday to be over but i'm also excited to celebrate it You
temptress, you, I know.
I didn't have dinner yet.
I'm hungry.
Marco!
Thank you so much for the five.
Good to thank you.
You're looking forward to it!
Well, get excited.
Get excited.
Can't wait to turn 19.
I don't know.
That's kind of scary turning 19.
Again.
What am I eating tonight?
I don't know.
What should I have?
I do have some leftovers.
I should probably have those.
I wasn't excited, but now I am.
Why weren't you excited before?
They are calling it the event of the year.
Skitty sounds good.
It's some spaghetti.
Feels like you were just 19 yesterday.
I know.
We grow up fast, and sometimes we don't grow.
I stopped growing in fifth grade.
I stopped.
I stopped growing.
Okay, Johnny's here, and now he's gone.
We can tell!
What do you mean you can tell?
It stopped in 9th grade.
That's not bad.
You made it to high school.
Wow.
But you know what?
You, I can't, I can't, you know what?
I didn't have, you know, I stopped my growing pains early.
All of you guys who are super tall and...
Hey, stop it.
Like super tall.
Yeah, you had to go through so many growing pains.
Ha ha ha.
I didn't.
It's a giant cup of coffee.
Watch, it can get even bigger.
It could if I felt like it.
There we go.
Oh, wait, where's it going?
Oops.
Ignore that.
Oh,
here we go, here we go.
Move my keyboard over a little bit.
There we go.
Is it okay to have an Uramishi Autumn?
Of course!
Wait!
Happy Autumn!
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go get Caramel Apple.
actually i have some fall activities planned um i can't say
just yet well like you know off stream unfortunately i'll
have stuff on stream of course but i have some some i'm
gonna really fully enjoy my autumn this year and yeah i'm
excited hmm trader joe's is going all out for fall again i
already got the hand lotion.
If you guys have a Trader Joe's by you, there is a, sorry
I'm slapping my thigh, there is a hand cream pumpkin cream.
It is the best hand cream.
You could ever, if you love the smell of pumpkin, if you
love, oh my gosh, it's so, it's so, hold on, let me go get
it and I'll Johnny come on I'm not feeding you but I'm gonna
give
you is it is the Trader Joe's pumpkin ultra moisturizing
hand cream with shea butter and pumpkin extract and this you
guys smells so good hey stop it stop it
if you need like a hand lotion if your hands get dry during
the colder months.
This is the stuff.
I put it on before I sleep and I have sweet dreams.
It's so good.
What, Johnny?
Do you want some?
He says no when he's leaving.
Yeah, it's my Osusume.
My recommendation.
my knuckles bleed every winter oh try this try this I don't
know though you might also need some extra stuff I mean this
is like great for dry hands general but if you have you know
I don't know if it'll do extreme dry hands but you know mmm
cats like pumpkin it helps with hair balls did I if I was in
the US I'd make my hand smell like my oh she's hands we need
to buy more we need to go in we need to look like we need to
go in and look like scalpers we need to go in and look like
scalpers we need to help every every u.s based ibu you must
help you must go and you must buy and then you must send to
to other ibu across the world
the pumpkin i'll do my part any any you i boo here right now
go to bed but also maybe in the discord be like help help i
need some pumpkin i love a pumpkin smell i love it i'm i
don't care if i i don't care if i look like those most white
girl ever ever ever to exist in history i'll get that
pumpkin spice latte i will i they only bring it out for like
two months of the year let me grab everything that i could
ever want of a pumpkin and enjoy it to the maximum fullest
for my two months it's 3 a.m yeah go to sleep uh pumpkin
head likes pumpkin smell check it out what do i do if i'm
not US or EU raise your hand and ask for help I don't like
Starbucks really but I do like that PSL yeah me too I don't
really like Starbucks either but I appreciate that a bunch
of other coffee shops do like pumpkin stuff too so I'm like
Minecraft drinking noise mmm mmm One thing I've been wanting
to do is I've been wanting to get a pumpkin and scoop out
the seeds and then roast them.
But for anybody who has done that, what kind of seasoning do
you put on your pumpkin seeds?
I was thinking maybe like a cinnamon maybe or something.
Pumpkin cream cheese muffin from Starbucks is my favorite
thing to get the...
Oh, God.
I just salt.
Maybe I can do, like, half salt.
Chili powder.
Okay, salt.
Just salt.
People eat the seeds.
If you roast them, it's actually really delicious.
Season salt.
Barbecue seasoning mix.
Woo.
Mmm.
Okay.
All spice and paprika.
Interesting.
Okay, I'm getting good ideas.
It was just kind of labor-intensive, so I only did it once.
That's why I haven't done it before.
But I want to try.
Over the garden wall, watch along.
Yeah, it's on the calendar.
It's on the calendar for next month.
My birthday is so soon.
That October is in one week.
A jack-o'-lantern.
That'll be fun.
Jack-o'-lantern.
We'll do that pumpkin stream, though.
The pumpkin stream.
It'll be your first year watching!
Oh my gosh, I love that.
I love when people...
You know, sometimes I'm like, so will people get sick of
watching over the garden wall every year but then of course
there may be a new person that have never seen it before so
you'll learn how good of a series it is fresh blood yes it
does also what I like to do is I like to look okay after
talking about the pumpkin now I realize I like to light it
sounds ridiculous because I love pumpkin smells so much but
I like to light a pumpkin candle and I like to open my
windows if it's nice and chilly out and I like to have like
a hot chocolate and cuddle with my blanket and watch it like
like that kind of do you like pumpkin pie yes yes I do yeah
so when I watch it with you guys I kind of like I make a
whole like
it you know and so how it's fall it's appropriate you've
never seen over the garden wall i hope you watch it this
year with us i'm gonna see if phoebe and vicky want to watch
it too even though it's a bit of a longer activity usually i
make the members but like a membu vaude but if i have the
both of them then i would not have it membu it would be oh
just the three of us we'll be watching it let's see i have
it on the calendar for let's see i have it on the calendar
for it's like a later
uh i have it for the 25th of october
so we shall see two hours long oh why do i always think it's
a five hour long thing She's planning so far and ahead.
My October already has so many things in.
I have to do because of the...
The charity stream.
I have to play Metal Gear Solid 4 the full game.
I have that planned for October as well.
I have the pumpkin game.
I have terrible lizards.
I have my Halloween stream.
Maybe if I do Rocky Horror, I'm so sad because I had the
Rocky Horror Watchalong.
I could do that as a Memboos, but I already had that on my
schedule.
And then...
I have to play MGS4.
Oh, darn.
I already had that on my schedule.
And then Tim Curry.
And so I was so sad.
I haven't seen over the garden wall.
I wanted to wait for you.
Then we'll watch it.
We'll watch it.
Yeah.
I'm deciding how I want to do the Metal Gear Solid 4.
I mean, I'm not going to skip cutscenes because I want to
watch them myself.
But I feel like I might play a little bit.
bit to get myself reacquainted with the game since it's been
a minute and kind of uh you know get a little bit
yeah back into it yeah get warm back up you made my day
rocky horror picture show means so much to me thank you of
course i watched nine to five after dolly it was oddly
comforting I mean it's nice though right to you know I know
like people will say oh morning an actor is so parasocial
but like these people influence lives right at the same time
they're like an actor or a musician so I loved nine to five
that movie is so funny
so I think you know I don't think it's weird at all to mourn
someone that had an influence on you or you enjoyed their
work like I think it's kind of like if you didn't that's
even weird or that's stranger you know like obviously Tim
Curry hasn't been in much in recently years but like he did
such amazing stuff and such great work so of course I'm
going to be sad that The person that contributed to so many
things is going to, is not around anymore, even if he
doesn't do any, even if he, like, didn't do anything, you
know, in recent years.
Robin Williams is a great example.
Hmm.
Also, Tim Curry isn't over the garden wall, so we'll get
double Tim Curry.
Yeah.
Parasocial has a meaning.
People just use psych lingo without knowing anything about
psych.
Yeah.
Yeah, so look at it.
Oh, Klu watch along.
That'd be so fun.
He was prolific in life.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did I hear over the garden wall?
You did, you did, you did.
Hello, Johnny.
Oh, my gosh, he's climbing me like a little baby.
Hello.
Yeah.
Went to see the Transformers, the movie, in theater the
other day is a big part.
Ah, stop it.
Because of Peter Colen, so totally get that.
No.
To this day, no celebrity death has hit me worse than Robin
Williams.
It's funny, I usually can't remember, like, you know, like,
I remember where I was for this big news announcement.
I can't remember where I was for any celebrity except
Michael Jackson.
Because I was at an anime game.
I was at an anime convention that had a TV on.
And I was like, Michael Jackson, found dead.
And I was like, and everybody was like, whoa.
So nah.
Yeah.
I was in a pottery class.
No way, you remember.
Yeah, this is not very sugoi at all.
I was at a freaking convention.
I was like cosplaying Toho.
I was cosplaying Toho when Michael Jackson died.
Gosh, dang.
Ah, making noise behind me.
It's so random.
Michael- Michael-san!
Which to who?
It either- I can't- it was either was Chen or Mistia.
Chen Yeah MJ would have played Toho Maybe Yeah let's just
say that Let's just say that Yeah You would rock that Chen
look Fan artists Who is my Yakumo Who is my Ran Yakumo Ran
Wait, Matara as Ron would be so funny though.
On it!
Satoranian Animism Street Wood.
I'm so bad at that game though.
I've done several Toho cosplays.
I've done Chen, Nui, Mystia, Journal.
It's funny.
I've done like so many besides like Reimu or Marisha I saw
so many of the tributes to Peter Colin from the VA community
Yeah, so many people who grew up in the 80s saw his optimus
as a replacement for a father they didn't have growing up
Wait, that's so sad Yeah It's kind of crazy how many super
influential like Creatives we've lost this year Hmm, you'd
make a great sakuya that's just because i'm a maid huh
you can definitely see you rocking new it if i get more if i
get more toho cosplay fan or maybe i'll do some more toho
streams i can use them for thumbnails yay oh patchy i did i
did cosplay patchy but i did a special version of a patchy
lee cosplay I did a special version.
Actually, one of my Toho cosplays was...
Actually, I was an extra in a movie.
It did not make it into the movie.
But...
My cosplay, I was Toho.
In the movie.
No.
I've only been an extra in a movie once.
I won't say which Toho, though.
What lore is this?
I wish I could tell you what actors were in it too.
But I think that might give it away.
So, secret, secret.
But they were like big, big name actors.
All of them were very nice.
except one of them he was a huge jerk and him and the and
the director were making fun of me they
were picking on me for my cosplay yeah even
I was like why trying to be an extra in a movie?
Uncultured.
I know.
How dare they insult Toho Project.
Must have been a bad movie.
But it was a fun experience.
It was a very long experience.
Have you guys ever tried being an extra in a movie?
Honestly, I think it's kind of I mean, it's not great money,
but it's a nice little side hustle.
And it's, they can be long hours, but it is quite fun, I'd
say.
I was one once, yeah.
Haven't had the opportunity.
If you look for them, I had a friend.
She, uh, she, she worked her way up.
Um, she moved to Atlanta, worked her way up as she would, so
basically, she told me about this in the walking dead there
are different different levels of zombie right and so it
starts as like um like you know a background super in like
you know just a just a mob zombie amongst all the others and
then you kind of move up to like a front facing zombie and
then you move up to like a super like screen time zombie and
she got to get killed by uh norman on screen she like she
was a zombie for so much in the walking dead that she like
leveled up her zombieness and then eventually got to be a
zombie that like i think she was the only one in that scene
and norman redis killed her so cool so cool yeah the norman
redis i know right i was like what when she told me i was
like no Why?
This is how the zombie mafia works.
Yeah, but I don't know.
I think, you know, the more you do it, the more you are an
extra, the more, like, you know, you'll maybe one day you'll
get a talking roll or something, like a little bit, like a
waitress or something.
So, this, too, is a strand.
This is a strand.
What?
I was...
What game?
I was watching somebody play a demo to a game that I I
watched them play the demo because the game itself is not
out yet But basically you play as a taxi driver You play as
a taxi driver in Japan and you are you know dropping people
off This and that and But you you play in these mountains
and the mountains are haunted and so spooky things happen
and sometimes you'll pick up like a ghost or something.
Crazy taxi.
You guys know only one taxi game.
Taxi driver, taxi driver, Japan.
But um But I want to play it.
So I was watching how the demo was because I was like if the
demo is good, then once the game comes out I'll stream it.
So I'm very excited about it.
But I was watching the gameplay and I was like this is a
Strand game.
This is a Strand game.
It was a Chillas Art game.
It was not.
But it looked kind of similar.
It looked a little similar, but better.
This is a Strand game.
Crazy Taxi.
Strand type game.
Sounds like a Yakuza mini game, too.
Ghosts or...
Kojima really did make a whole genre.
When I play it, I hope you guys know what I'm talking about.
Hold on, let me see what the game is called.
I can't remember.
What was it?
Oh.
It was...
I'm hoping that it comes out.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, road to Jukai.
Road to Jukai, if you want to look up the game, like on
Steam or something.
Ah, you found it!
You found it, seasoned egg.
Nice.
Yeah, that was it.
That was it.
Did you read the Kojima Interest?
in which he describes Death Stranding World was empty
because he spent the budget on Hollywood actors.
That's so him.
Road to Jukai.
Oh, wait, I should, wait, I think I wishlisted it already.
Let me double.
Oh, yeah, I did.
Yeah, it looks neat.
You work the night shift as a taxi driver in a remote region
of Japan.
Not all the odd passengers you pick up after sunset are what
they seem sometimes it's safer to just keep your eyes on the
road especially when a fair leads to the strange massive
forest the locals whisper about death stranding was full of
like people that you think you wouldn't even see like why
why was conan o'brien
Did you watch the actor reveal trailer for Fizent?
I did?
And I was, I don't know anybody.
I was like, oh, neat.
Why not Conan O'Brien's?
Yeah, I didn't know who anybody was.
I, I'm, you know, I'm like, woohoo.
We memed ourselves out of thinking it could be Pattinson.
Wait, what do you mean?
Wait, did people think it was going to be Robert Pattinson?
That would have been the best thing actually ever.
That would have been the best thing so much.
I would have loved that.
cameos in the next game.
We'll just get more Pecora.
I know Kojima really likes her.
Norman Redis wearing the hat, the Peckel hat, was so cute.
The MC is Pec- Oh!
Oh!
I see!
Wait, that'll be awesome!
Oh!
That guy has such a face.
Like, I want I loved watching his interviews where he would
be like, here, let me do the creepy...
Here, I'll do the creepy Pennywise face.
And then he would just like distort his face to do it.
Hearing him say, Otsu Pekko gave me life.
Ooh.
Pekora was my first Oshi, but he'll always be my favorite.
Thank you.
Pekora is a great Oshi to have.
She's a really good streamer.
She's a great streamer.
I find myself more often or like more more and more watching
watching Corona recently.
I'll just kind of have her on while I'm working and stuff.
Tim Curry was Pennywise too.
Everything leads back to Tim Curry.
Corona is great.
I feel I watch her and I feel like because she was one of
the early like hollow lives that I watched.
I mean, same with a bunch of people, right?
So I, when I watch, I feel like a sense of kind of like it's
so weird that nostalgia for 2020 is kind of at least for the
vtuber scene it feels a little like welcoming even though it
was such a tumultuous year obviously tumultuous time but
back then the community was so I mean I was there I was in
the thick it oh yeah 2020 was rough but it was a special
time yeah yeah it was a special time for for vtubers i mean
yeah when they started really popping off the the boom of
the vtubers at least globally right I was there I was there
We'll be celebrating my six years Alright, it's a little
late It's just gonna be like a little simple karaoke Hope
you guys don't mind But You know We could talk about Lots of
stuff Six years Six years of streaming I'm old I'm so old
I'm glad that you guys still watch me You're not sick of me
And And that You know Thanks for For sticking around And you
know I hope that You know I know there's whole like kind of
idol culture With VTubers and everything I know i like you
know obviously i'm in an idol group but i hope that also i
can kind of just become like a constant like just regular
streamer that you'll want to watch as well um just kind of
be like oh what's on oh minto's playing a game
six almost seven years here all right Takanashi!
Shut up!
You already are for me?
Yay!
I'm glad, I'm so glad.
I'm so glad, I'm so glad.
You're pretty good.
I think I'll keep coming back.
Thanks.
Hag-oshi.
It's so funny.
I saw a thing for Vexpo, actually, where it was like, this
is the wall of VTuber hags.
And guess who wasn't on the list?
I was like, I've dodged it.
I've dodged it.
You're literally the only streamer whose schedule I check.
Really?
Don't sell yourselves short.
I spent six years of making schedules it's so crazy I'm so
old does discord agree with that do they need does discord
need to know what do they need to know what do they need to
know she can't get away with this yeah I mean I'm 19 so like
saying that I'm hag status is just kind of weird no it's
weird it's weird I put you on the Oshi Epplinck hag wall.
No, you didn't.
No.
He's been very patient.
So I think I'll go feed him now.
First VTuber I got and gifted Vembees for.
Sasquatch, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Really appreciate that.
The hag wall wasn't too big.
That's even worse than that I'm there.
That's even worse!
Yeah, Johnny's been very patient and his feeding is about
now.
So I guess I'll go feed.
I'll go feed the little guy.
Crazy to think.
I've been here almost half your streaming career.
Feels like just yesterday I started watching again.
I hope to keep watching it for many years ago.
Nixie, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy fall on the Fuminto topic.
For anyone looking to suppress her dominance, turns out size
2T3T seems to work.
She actually is toddler size.
No way.
Wait, that's insane.
Thanks for the fun stream.
I hope you have a yummy dinner and a great night.
Thank you so much.
Fakety, thank you as well.
Thank you for the pinks.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Toddler, what was it?
2T3T?
What does that mean?
Two months, three months?
Johnny, I know, you've been so patient, you've been a good
boy.
I'll go feed you now.
Alrighty guys, this is game changing knowledge.
I don't want to know why you know this.
Did you bring like your Fuminto plush to like a baby store
and tried stuff out?
How did you figure this out?
Hold on.
I'll stop the music, see if he has any last parting words.
I don't know.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
Thank you guys!
I'm doing my best.
I'm not very confident.
I'm not too much.
I'm just so...
Thank you.
Okay, Johnny.
Johnny.
Johnny, what is your wisdom?
You heard it here first, folks.
Blind ordered happened to work out.
I think it's two year, three year.
No, it's not that big at all.
You heard it here first, folks.
When life is sad, you should.
Yeah.
Thank you everybody, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you.
I hope you had a good time.
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time zone.
I will see you when I see you next.
Outsu- Outsu-mitu.
See you, see you, bye bye.
Johnny, say bye bye.
Okay.
He's getting grumpy.
Bye bye.
Huh.